[Musique]
Raphaël Rossello, Owen Simonin, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview et nous
sommes en direct. Raphaël, est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
et on suivra après avec Owen ?
Pas de souci. Euh je suis banquier
d'affaires de ce que j'appelle
l'économie réelle et depuis peu je suis
essayiste et lanceur d'alerte.
Owen.
Je suis un jeune entrepreneur et je
réalise également du contenu et des
vidéos sur internet principalement
autour de la problématique et des sujets
qu'apportent toutes les problématiques
des cryptoonnaies, de la blockchain, de
ces nouvelles technologies, de ce
qu'elles peuvent apporter, mais
également de de toute l'évolution de cet
écosystème en général. Alors, on a
choisi de vous de vous recevoir tous les
deux ce soir avec tout votre respect,
tout notre respect, un vieux et un jeune
pour discuter autour de des évolutions
de la cryptomonnaie, de la récession,
des des de trois choses qui sont en
train de nous tomber dessus. On a décidé
vous deux, Raphaël était déjà passé et
avait reçu un accueil très chaleureux de
la communauté et Owen nous a été
recommandé un peu par tout le monde et
on s'est rendu compte que vous vous
connaissiez tous les deux et donc et
donc ça tombait bien, ça s'est bien
coupé. Avant de commencer cette émission
et précaution oratoire, on va parler de
produits financiers. C'est très risqué,
c'est très dangereux, on ne conseille à
personne quoi que ce soit.
Euh et euh si vous avez des choses à
rajouter au cours de de l'interview, on
vous laissera faire. Donc ça n'est que à
caractère informatif, non pas pour faire
de l'investissement, mais pour
comprendre ce qui se passe. Et autre
chose, on va commencer doucement parce
qu'il y a il y a aussi des débutants
autour de ces sujets-là. On va monter
progressivement en puissance et puis
après on vous laissera partir où vous
voulez. Raphaël, on va commencer par toi
et par vous, pardon. Non non non, on
peut se tutoyer
et donc on va commencer par toi. Euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment ?
C'est une question ouverte. Quelle est
la lecture du vieux banquier d'affaires
qui a toujours un pied dans le boulot,
qui a toujours un réseau connecté aux
entreprises, aux entrepreneurs et ainsi
de suite qui prend la température ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment,
Raphaël ?
Alors, on a incontestablement
euh un sentiment global d'incertitude,
un sentiment de mal-être, un sentiment
de d'inquiétude.
Et ce sentiment, il n'est pas que
français. Je je l'ai avec mes copains à
Toronto, en Belgique, en Suisse, en
Italie et cetera.
Je je je je
vous livre le processus que j'ai conduit
pour comprendre pour essayer de
comprendre la problématique dans dans
laquelle nous sommes que je vais
qualifier tout au long de notre
entretien ce soir de grandes régressions
et et et vous allez comprendre pourquoi
j'utilise ce terme.
après vous avoir fait un petit peu peur,
vous inquiétez pas, je j'apporterai les
beaux et les pilules du bonheur qui vont
qui vont bien en fait pour parfaitement
c'est cynique. C'est cynique cette
réflexion. Elle n'est pas cynique. Elle
est tout à fait réaliste. Elle est tout
à fait réaliste. En fait, pour essayer
de faire ça en max une petite dizaine de
minutes, je vous propose une approche à
la fois
macro globale société et puis après une
approche micro, les entreprises.
On a le temps de déléguer tout ça.
Oui, absolument.
Euh sur l'approche globale,
en fait, il faut repartir du fait que
l'homme a toujours recherché
l'éternité.
Euh sa finitude
l'a toujours angoissé et on peut
considérer que l'homme est devenu
conscient de sa nature humaine le jour
où il a enterré ses morts.
Pourquoi je dis ça ? parce que pendant
des millénaires
euh
le religieux
a permis d'apaiser cette angoisse de du
néant après la mort
de la canaliser
ou ou de la canaliser absolument et bien
entendu ça a été exploité par tous les
pouvoirs politiques qui en ont fait un
objet de servitude d'obscurantisme.
Par chance, nous sommes nous en France
et en Europe
euh
dans le creusé
qui dans les années 1700 et quelques a
vu naître en Angleterre et en France
principalement les idées libérales
plutôt économiques en Angleterre et les
idées libérales plutôt sociologiques et
politiques en France.
La conjugaison des deux a donné cette
notion des lumières par opposition à
l'obscurantisme.
Mais il y avait néanmoins ce souci
d'éternité.
Et ce souci d'éternité s'est exprimé de
façon très concrète
par le progrès avec un grand paix.
Et sans être pédant, je ne citerai que
Victor Hugo ce soir qui à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale en 1848
avait dit "Le progrès, c'est d'améliorer
le sort des classes souffrantes.
Se battre pour la dignité des pauvres."
Absolument.
Et je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que le progrès, c'est
effectivement le progrès matériel
des êtres qui sont en souffrance
matérielle.
Et de ce point de vue-là, le progrès
était au service de l'homme et pas
l'inverse.
Le progrès technologique.
Le progrès avec un grand paix, il est il
est humain, il est social, il est dans
l'éducation, dans la santé,
dans le sens.
Il est dans le sens. Il est dans le
sens. Bien.
et coïncidence en fait çaen ça n'en est
pas une mais dans mon dans ma dans mon
analyse
ça a été le le point de convergence
c'est que
pendant 200 ans,
ce progrès a été accompagné de ce que
nous appelons nous aujourd'hui la
croissance
en rappelant que ce mot de croissance
n'avait jamais existé pendant ces 200
ans.
En fait, le mot de croissance est arrivé
dans les années 60 70 alors que de 1750
ou 1770 à 1970, non, on parlait du
développement, on parlait du progrès,
euh on parlait de l'expansion, mais on
n'utilisait pas le terme de croissance.
Et de manière à avoir un discours le
plus clair possible ce soir, je vais
utiliser le terme de bio.
C'est pas des poireaux ou des tomates,
mais la croissance de ces deux siècles,
elle était bio. Il y avait pas d'engrais
chimique. Il y avait
comment dirais-je ? Il y avait
une croissance que j'ai qualifié dans
mon ouvrage de naturel
autonome.
Comment il s'appelle l'ouvrage ?
L'opportunité du Covid. Mais le sous-tit
je le préfère, c'est comment construire
demain autrement.
C'est pas un bouquin sur les théories de
Ricardo.
Ah, pas du tout du tout du tout du tout.
Non non, c'est c'est un c'est un manuel
qui explique comment on en est là et
pourquoi on en est là. Parce que si on
arrive pas à esquisser des raisons de de
de ce pourquoi et ben on va appliquer et
je vais revenir dessus après, on va
appliquer de mauvais de mauvais médoc
pour pour nous soigner.
Ce progrès donc matériel économique
a permis en dépit des crise, des
guerres, des émeutes, des grèves qui ont
été
terminées dans le sang et cetera ont
malgré tout permis de sortir l'humanité
de sa misère
ancestrale.
Et je ne comprenais pas comment dans les
années 90 2000 2010,
il y avait de mon point de vue sur le
terrain, il y avait une sorte de
désynchronisation
entre le discours politique
et la réalité de terrain.
Et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
découvert
que depuis 1970,
en fait la croissance est en déclin et
si on s'amuse ce que j'ai fait et bien
entendu, j'ai validéraction
banale, j'ai je l'ai fait valider par
des hommes du chiffre.
Si on déduit d'un agrégat financier les
éléments négatifs qui lui correspondent,
je dis, j'affirme que depuis 40 ans, la
France est en récession. Bien. Alors,
quand je dis ça, pour beaucoup d'entre
vous et beaucoup des gens que je
rencontre sur ce thème me disent "Mais
c'est pas possible, qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire ?" Je vais l'exprimer de la
façon la plus concrète possible
et après on passera la parole à Owen.
Absolument parce queen Owen peut peut
apporter justement des lueurs
d'espérance par rapport au diagnostic
que je pose.
D'où l'intérêt que j'ai eu quand tu m'as
dit que nous allions nous allions être
tous les deux. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
que si je fais les calculs qui vont
bien,
si nous n'avions pas en France, en
Angleterre, aux États-Unis et cetera,
nous n'avions pas eu une politique de
l'endettement
massif public et privé, on ne parle que
de la dette publique. Il faut savoir que
la dette privée, elle est toujours deux
fois plus importante que la publique.
Aujourd'hui,
le PIB de la France devrait être 25 %
inférieur
à ce qu'il est. Quand je dis
aujourd'hui, c'est bien sûr juste avant
le Covid euh le Covid ayant exacerbé euh
le le le problème. Bien
donc en fait et ce chiffre de 25 %
d'ailleurs, il est relativement sympa
parce que quand je fais les mêmes
calculs sur les États-Unis, je suis à
mo- 40 %.
C'est-à-dire que c'est c'est comme si à
peu près on a la même taille Owen 1,80
plus. C'est comme si 40 à 50 cm de notre
taille n'était que le fait d'un d'un
traitement artificiel.
Et à partir du moment où l'on admet
et et je vous implore, je vous supplie
de croire que ce que je dis n'est pas de
la folie, c'est que vous allez regarder
le futur de façon totalement différente.
Et à l'occasion de mon dernier passage
qui était le premier en fait chez toi,
j'ai été interpellé par pas mal de gens
qui m'ont dit "Bon, il est sympa le
boomer mais mais concernant les cryptos
et machin, il y comprend rien." Et je
remercie tous ceux qui m'ont attiré dans
cette sphère et qui m'a permis justement
d'avoir un échange avec Owen.
Owen, la la patate chaude derrière
Raphaël.
cette lourde responsabilité d'apporter
des lueurs d'espoir à la jeunesse. On va
commencer par si on peut se tutoyer
bien sûr
par toi. Euh pourquoi les cryptos ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est les cryptos ? Euh un
sujet quelques minutes d'introduction et
et et qu'est-ce que ça peut apporter
comme solution ? Qu'est-ce que ça peut
apporter comme
Alors, les cryptoonnaies sont basées sur
la technologie de la blockchain. Les
cryptomonnaies sont des usages de la
blockchain, tout comme les sites sont
des usages d'Internet, par exemple. Le
parallèle est très très bon et peut être
pris à de sous de nombreux angles.
Ce qui m'a réellement intéressé dans les
cryptoonnaies au début comme beaucoup de
monde, c'est la spéculation hein. Au
départ, j'en ai entendu parler quand il
y a eu une surmédiatisation des
cryptomonnaies et quand il y a
surmédiatisation, c'est parce qu'il y a
grosse valorisation ou
grosse dépréciation des cours des
cryptomonnaes. cette surmédiatisation
qui m'en a fait enfin ce qui fait que
les cryptomonnaaies sont arrivées à mes
oreilles que je me suis intéressé à ce
que c'était. moi qui joue beaucoup aux
jeux vidéos, qui suis dans l'univers du
gaming, qui quand j'étais encore plus
jeune jouait à toutes sortes de jeux
vidéos, je me suis dit waouh, il y a
quelque chose d'intéressant et
d'incroyable à avoir du coup cette
monnaie purement numérique, virtuelle et
découvrir comment ça fonctionne.
Et j'ai lu pour le coup, je pense avoir
eu le le bon point d'accroche. Je me
suis intéressé à Bitcoin, la plus grosse
cryptonnaie et je suis tombé sur comment
fonctionne le Bitcoin, comment ça marche
et naturellement avant de mettre de
l'argent dans quelque chose, j'ai voulu
gratter la surface et pour le coup, je
gratte encore la surface aujourd'hui
hein parce que plus on prend plus on
prend conscience de cet écosystème, plus
on se rend compte qu'il est vaste et
qu'on ne sait rien. Et j'ai compris
assez rapidement une ligne fondamentale
qui m'a choqué à l'époque parce que ce
n'était pas possible pour moi, jeune
homme qui était dans les jeux vidéos qui
avait compris qu'on pouvait avoir des
valorisations numériques, donc quelque
chose de virtuel, un logiciel, des
points, une armure dans un jeu. On était
prêt à payer pour ça, mais ça n'avait
pas de rareté. C'est-à-dire qu'on
pouvait le copier, le coller à l'infini.
C'est un logiciel superbeau tournant
d'IBM qui passe du hardware au software
pour toucher le monde entier. et
énormément d'entreprises. On était
vraiment dans un tournant où le logiciel
commença à prendre d'autant plus
d'importance que le hardware.
Et là, je découvre que on peut également
avoir quelque chose de bel et bien
virtuel, de bel et bien numérique et de
pourtant totalement unique. une certaine
unicité, quelque chose d'inviolable et
quelque chose que bien que ce soit
uniquement sur internet ce soit cadré et
on ne puisse pas tout simplement
contrôle C, contrôle V, copier coller à
l'infini. Et là, à ce moment-là, ça a
été un gros gros gros changement dans ma
vie parce que j'ai ressenti quelque
chose. J'avais l'impression d'avoir de
l'or entre les mains. En tout cas, c'est
le sentiment que ça créé chez moi. J'ai
compris ensuite que c'était ce qu'on
appelle le faux mot. Ferror Missing Out,
c'est un peu plus loin que ça parce que
c'est les fondamentaux. Et là, je me
suis senti totalement dépassé par ce que
je venais de découvrir. Et moi qui
aimais beaucoup les investissements sur
internet, les jeux, les points et tout
ce qu'on pouvait faire dans cet univers
là, là je me suis rendu compte que ça
venait pas uniquement du Bitcoin.
D'ailleurs, faut savoir que Bitcoin avec
un petit B, c'est la le jeton Bitcoin
que l'on s'échange. Bitcoin avec un
grand B, c'est le nom de la blockchain
Bitcoin. Déjà, ça donne vraiment envie
aux débutants de s'y intéresser. C'est
c'est une base très simple pour démarrer
dans cet écosystème. Et et donc là, je
me suis rendu compte de la puissance de
la blockchain Bitcoin qui était non
seulement un proof of concept puisque
c'est la toute première qui a montré que
c'était possible mais qui était
également porteur de toutes ces valeurs
d'une certaine décentralisation,
transparence et petit à petit, je me
suis enfoncé dans cet écosystème et j'ai
fait un constat très simple. C'est
incroyable et ça permet de régler des
problèmes qui jusqu'alors étaient connus
mais qui ne n'avaient aucune solution.
Il y avait aucun moyen technique et
humain pour le moment tout du moins de
régler ces problèmes. Et là, petit à
petit, j'ai commencé à jouer parce que
c'était un jeu pour moi de découvrir
tout ça, de découvrir ses points, leur
nature. Ce n'était pas un travail, ce
n'était pas une recherche et je n'avais
pas de recul sur le monde, la finance,
les problèmes, l'économie. J'étais
vraiment dans un waouh. Il y a un truc
phénoménal, une nature encore inconnue.
Et là, je sens qu'il y a un potentiel.
C'était quelle année ça ?
2000 fin 2015 début 2016.
La création du Bitcoin, c'est quand déjà
?
Euh, on est sur les premiers
balbussements, les premières discussions
fin 2008, si je dis pas de bêtises,
octobre 11 octobre 2008. Il a fêté son
anniversaire il y a pas longtemps et
ensuite la première fois que le
protocole a fonctionné, il me semble que
c'était 2009. J'en profite pour
reprendre la parole. Euh si vous
m'entendez bien, mettez-moi un petit
message sur le le chat. Et si vous si
vous entendez pas bien, il faut pas
hésiter de nous dire "On a un câble qui
frisote." Euh revenons à nos moutons.
Alors, à l'heure actuelle, le marché des
Bitcoin, c'est 2500 3000 milliards.
D'accord ? Là, je vais vous lire une
question internet qui qui vient de me
passer devant les yeux qui est très
intéressante.
Question : que pensent vos invités des 2
% des utilisateur Bitcoin qui auraient
la main mise sur 95 % des Bitcoin
existants, donc manipulation possible à
Outrance, quit des tweets d'on Musk avec
ses 64 millions d'abonnés qui manipulent
entre guillemets également les cryptos
et les actions par un simple tweet.
Alors ça c'est l'affirmation de la
personne qui pose la question. On va
attendre que l'enquête des des autorités
des marchés financiers rendent leur
conclusion bien entendu. Raphaël,
alors
euh le le point de jonction sur lequel
on va se on va se retrouver est le
suivant. Première partie, c'est c'est la
partie macro
de de cette situation de grande
régression.
La partie micro et c'est celle qui
m'intéresse professionnellement,
c'est que
pour la faire le plus court possible,
aujourd'hui depuis maintenant
20 30 ans, je n'ai plus les fournisseurs
de capitaux en adéquation
avec le monde de l'entreprise entre
guillemets traditionnel.
Ils ne financent plus, ils veulent que
de du rendement.
Attends. Alors, c'est que il y a un
dictate qui vient de euh d'un article,
je me souviens de la date, généralement,
je j'ai pas la mémoire des dates, mais
c'était le jour de la mort de mon père,
le 13 septembre 1970.
Et à son âme.
Ouais.
Et
Milton Friedman
a publié dans le New York Times un
article au moment où General Motors
était dans un dans un débat entre ses
actionnaires et la société civile et la
société politique d'une manière générale
sur est-ce que l'objet social d'une
entreprise peut intégrer ce qu'elle a
été depuis des je dirais depuis le
Moyen-Âge.
C'est-à-dire avoir non seulement
l'obligation de rendre du profit à ses
actionnaires, mais également euh d'avoir
une vocation au-delà de cela. Et là,
Freedman a tranché dans le vif en disant
"Non, non, non, non, non, non. Le seul
et unique objet d'une entreprise, c'est
de dégager le maximum de profit."
Alors, je suis un capitaliste,
j'accompagne des capitalistes et surtout
je constate que dans toutes les sociétés
humaine, s'il n'y a pas un surplus qu'on
appelle le profit, la société meurt.
Donc de toute façon, il y a pas de
débat, il faut qu'il y ait du profit.
Mais là où je considère que ce maximum
est assassin, c'est que si je veux
chercher le maximum d'une entreprise, et
ben je vais le faire au détriment de ses
fournisseurs, je vais le faire au
détriment de ses employés, je vais le
faire au détriment de ses clients, je
vais être en mesure de de presser le
fruit le plus possible uniquement dans
le but de générer le maximum de profit.
Et à partir de de ce moment-là, je
constate que le capitalisme dit
financier s'est organisé depuis 40 ans,
de sorte que les canaux de distribution
de cette épargne fléché vers les
entreprises
avait des
comment dirais-je des exigences
qui certes étaient parfaitement
compatibles avec, allez, on va dire dans
ma carrière le tiers ou le quart de mes
clients qui sont des entreprises très
innovantes, très agiles, très flexibles,
très bien. Mais pour tous les autres de
l'économie traditionnelle, dans l'agro,
les services généraux et autres, je suis
en en inadéquation
entre les fournisseurs de capitaux et
mes entrepreneurs.
Toi, tu ne tu ne pressures pas tes
entrepreneurs.
Mais c'est c'est pas ça. c'est que je je
pense à l'un d'eux qui me regarde
peut-être ce soir. Il emploie 1400
personnes en France, il a six usines, il
est dans la transformation de la
métallerie, il est absolument impossible
alors qu'il a robotisé le maximum et
cetera, il lui est absolument impossible
de servir plus de 4 à 5 % du capital
investi. Et comme la dette qu' lève,
elle est pour acheter des machines
ou des ou des établissements, voilà, il
il peut pas deper artificiellement comme
j'ai essayé de le démontrer au niveau du
PIB, il ne peut pas doppper sa
performance. Et c'est là où euh je
découvre que une une des aspirations de
la technologie blockchain dont Owen
vient de de de nous parler, en fait, il
y avait deux éléments. Il y avait un
élément de décentralisation
et un élément d'être une source
potentiellement de financement
alternatif.
Et c'est là où euh depuis le mois de mai
juin, donc c'est tout récent depuis 6
mois, je suis plongé dans ces aventures
en accompagnant d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de de d'hommes et de femmes qui
sont en train d'essayer de de
cristalliser autour de la blockchain et
des cryptos des projets euh
concrets
concrets et que je vais justement
utiliser
Enfin, c'est ce que j'espère à l'égard
des entreprises traditionnelles. Je vois
déjà plein d'obstacles dont on parlera
peut-être, mais mon espérance par
rapport à cet univers que j'ai découvert
qui est le tien, c'est de dire bah
puisque le système tel qu'il a été conçu
depuis 40 ans n'est plus en adéquation
avec mon fond de commerce,
comment puis-je arriver à adresser les
besoins de ce fond de commerce ? Owen,
est-ce que tu veux rebondir là-dessus ou
tu veux que je t'envoie des questions ?
Alors, on peut partir sur des questions.
C'est vrai que à un moment, on va
échanger sur tout ça et moi c'est ce qui
m'avait marqué quand j'ai regardé ton du
coup ton Finkerview. Du coup, bah nous
on s'est appelé pour la première fois
hier et moi c'est vrai que le moment où
le Bitcoin est un billet de monopoie.
Ah, vous m'avez pas dit que vous vous
étiez appelé hier.
Mais mais on l'a dit juste avant,
c'était ça se connaissait déjà. Je le
dis,
on s'est parlé 5 minutes et pour être
totalement franc, Finkerview, c'était
quelque chose pour moi. Et du coup,
naturellement, moi je me suis penché sur
le Finkerview que Raphaël avait déjà
fait. Et là, une grosse découverte de
beaucoup de choses durant toute la
vidéo. Mais à la fin, on a enchaîné
quatre questions sur les cryptonnaies.
Un billet de monopoie, euh ça ça ne vaut
rien, c'est basé sur du vent. euh que
des choses qui sont fausses et puis
jusqu'à la fameuse prise de parole de
Christine Lagarde, le Bitcoin n'est pas
une monnaie. Waouh ! On avait des choses
à se dire
et c'est ça qui fait que ça m'a vraiment
donné beaucoup de curiosité et je
voulais construire sur ce débat parce
que là où je pensais qu'il y aurait eu
un mauvais fond, j'ai vu une vraie
volonté de faire un constat et de dire
"OK, maintenant on pousse tout,
qu'est-ce qu'il existe ? Qu'est-ce que
l'on peut faire ?" et surtout pas de
fausses promesses parce que le Bitcoin
n'est pas non plus arrivé avec toutes
les promesses du monde et il n'est pas
là pour soigner tous les mots du monde
non plus. En attendant, il est en train
de construire et de proposer des outils
qui seront peut-être un jour,
d'ailleurs, j'aime bien le dire, les
meilleurs usages de Bitcoin et des
fondements qu'il portent n'ont peut-être
même pas encore été pensés. Et donc à un
moment, il faut des gens qui veulent
think
des opératifs
et il faut naturellement des gens de la
finance traditionnelle qui décident de
faire ce point de pivot. Et je pensais
vraiment qu'aujourd'hui ce serait pas du
tout un point de pivot et ce serait un
vrai conflit basé sur un sujet. Et je
n'avais pas du tout vu venir le fait que
et ça ne m'étonne finalement que
moyennement parce que quand on dit
quelque chose de factuellement faux et
qu'on s'en rend compte, il y a deux
moyens. Soit on se braque et non, soit
on creuse, on comprend, on avance. Et je
ne suis que moyennement surpris après
avoir vu les 2 heures de prise de parole
que que vous avez déjà faites sur cette
chaîne. Et c'est là que je me suis dit
en réalité, est-ce qu'on va débattre ou
est-ce que je vais apprendre quelque
chose ? Et je pense que c'est un mélange
des deux en fait et c'est ça qui
m'intéressait énormément.
Donc ça peut être des questions, on peut
tout de suite rebondir.
Alors pardon, je je te
je vous laisse je vous laisse gérer.
Allez-y.
D'accord. Enf, en en fait euh euh je
pense que l'intérêt
euh pour les internautes ce soir,
il est il est multiple hein, mais il y
en a deux principaux.
Le premier,
je je j'insiste lourdement, c'est que
quand vous voyez tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui vous
parlent croissance
dans
à chaque fois que je je que mon cortex
percute ce mot de croissance, je le
traduis instantanément
en régression. Qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de me promettre dans la mesure où
depuis 40 ans, il n'y a pas on ne peut
pas envisager que ce soit réversible, il
n'y a pas d'autre croissance qu'une
croissance
euh démesurée
de l'endettement.
Juste un chiffre, Juste un chiffre. Si
la croissance des 40 dernières années en
France, même chose dans les autres pays
occidentaux,
avait été sincèrement la même que celle
d'avant, celle que je qualifiais de bio.
OK. En gros, la richesse nationale
aurait doublé en 40 ans. OK, je vous ai
dit en fait, elle a pas doublé, elle a
régressé de 25 %. Au même moment, la
dette publique a été multipliée par 10
et la dette globale a été multipliée par
4. Donc pour n'obtenir qu'un doublement
de la production de biens et de services
qui est la vraie richesse, il a fallu
s'endetter quatre fois plus. Bien,
ça c'est le premier élément. Le deuxième
c'est
et je peux sincèrement vous dire que
dans l'univers que je représente, je le
disais en en préambule avant qu'on ne
soit à l'antenne,
il n'y a pas dans ma communauté de gens
qui soient dans le niveau de conscience
que j'ai découverte
d'un monde où vous me considérez comme
étant déjà du passé,
hein. Et c'est là où je trouve ma
position de ce soir absolument
extraordinaire, c'est que je fais figure
effectivement de papi boomer, mais vous
vous m'avez accueilli et je pense aux
Jérémie, aux Stéphanie, aux Éie qui me
regardent ce soir et qui m'emmènent dans
leur projet
blockchain. OK.
et de l'autre côté des gens qui
considèrent c'estàd mon univers
professionnel qui considèrent que pour
le moment c'est une bande de nanar qui
d'anarchiste terme et comme je l'avais
anarchiste dans le bon sens du terme.
Ouais, mais comme je te l'avais dit la
première fois où je suis passé, le fait
que mon père soit passé par l'anarchie
euh en Catalogne qui avait failli être
un succès si elle n'avait pas été cassée
euh par le parti communiste à l'époque,
il eû resté, même si c'était un grand
scientifique et un petit patron, il lui
restait ce réflexe de toujours envisager
l'autre.
L'autre, d'accord ?
Ça c'est les vrais anarchistes.
C'est les vrais anarchistes. D'accord.
Ce sont ceux qui ne sont pas dans un
militantisme dogmatique en disant
"Ouais, c'est c'est un riche, c'est un
machin." Non, écoutons l'autre. Or, moi
je me dis aujourd'hui
et et là je je vous exprime par contre
une véritable angoisse par rapport à
tous les jeunes qui m'entourent, c'est
nos nos gouvernants ne réalisent pas la
situation dans laquelle nous trouvons
réellement. J'espère qu'il le réalise.
J'espère mais je je j'en suis pas
certain.
Faire l'avocat du diable une seule
seconde.
Bon alors l'avocat du diable concernant
la dette. Là tu connais le la la la
ritournelle de oui mais c'est
l'investissement à long terme vous
comprenez ? C'est les voies ferrées, les
aéroports, les trucs à long terme, c'est
normal, il faut faire ça. Première
avocat du diable.
Deuxème avocat du diable.
Quand quand nos partis quand tu parles
de nos partis politiques, est-ce que on
va éviter les partis polyquistes pour
parce que la la majeure partie du temps,
il brasent de la fumée, il sculpte de
l'air chaud et quand on les prend en
détail, les yeux dans les yeux sur des
sujets techniques comme l'énergie, la
production nucléaire, la cheminement
d'énergie, l'hydrogène et en fait les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
société occidentale, on les voit et ils
partent en morceaux. Et oui, mais
quand ils essayent pas de prendre le
contrôle de la dialectique quand ils
sont en public, en vous en vous évacuant
d'un revers de la vin comme quoi c'est
trop technique. Donc éclusons les partis
politiques, parlons de nos institutions,
de nos fonctionnaires, de nos cellules
de prospective qui depuis 40 ans se
payent avec nos impôts pour faire de la
prospective qui finit en général dans
une poubelle ou dans un coin de bureau.
Et pour revenir au leader de parti
politique qui accède à la place de de
pouvoir,
ces gens-là, ils ont aucun intérêt à
vous dire que demain on va se faire
démonter par une crise énergétique. On
va se faire démonter par une crise de
matériaux de matière première parce que
ça fait pas voter.
Alors
pourquoi pourquoi Macron réengage le
programme thermonucléaire français ?
pour avoir discuté pendant des heures et
des heures avec Bernard Zambert, le
fondateur du programme thermonucléaire
français conseiller de des plus grands.
Euh on sait pourquoi on réengage le
nucléaire
parce que toute croissance est basée sur
de la consommation énergétique et c'est
pour ça que je vais pouvoir enchaîner
avec Owen concernant la soutenabilité
énergétique des coins. C'est c'est
intéressant mais ton raisonnement ton
raisonnement est est très concret.
Alors, attends, je je voudrais juste
rebondir sur le mot de therm
thermodynamique.
En réalité, c'est
le point d'inflexion de ce progrès,
hein. On on est passé de ce rêve
d'éternité, le progrès, la croissance et
cetera. En fait, on était et il y a un
garçon qui s'appelle Kangilem qui a qui
a écrit dans les années 80,
comment ça s'appelle ? C A N G U I L H E
M Bon et il a fait un article sur les
déconvenus de de du du progrès. Je je me
souvenais plus exactement du titre mais
ou ou la désillusion du projet enfin
quelque chose comme ça. Et en fait, il
fait référence justement au fait que
dans l'esprit des lumières qui anime
l'essentiel de nos sociétés, hein, mais
justement la lumière, elle elle donnait
un sentiment d'éternité, de perpétuité.
Or, en réalité, ce sont les deux ou
trois grands principes de la
thermodynamique
qui sont à l'origine de notre inflexion,
c'est que le rendement
euh humain et économique de la machine
que nous connaissons est devenu négatif.
Le rendement a été positif pendant 200
ans, il est devenu négatif. Donc merci
d'évoquer ce terme de de thermodynamique
parce que en réalité il est une des
explications et il y en a plein
d'autres, il est une des explications de
cette de cette bascule. Je reviens
simplement avant de te passer la parole
sur
Merci.
Non non mais sur sur le problème euh
crypto
ou la solution
ou la solution. En fait d'abord il y a
pas de solution miracle. Donc, je
considère que tous les partis politiques
aujourd'hui sont des populistes dans la
mesure où il il continue de présenter la
recherche de cette croissance économique
comme étant la solution. C'est en droit,
on appelle ça un DL. Moi,
et ou une cavalerie
ou une cavalerie. Bon or le le problème
c'est que quand on est conscient comme
je le suis parce que ça fait ça fait ça
fait 20 ans que je me questionne et ça
fait 8 ans que j'ai pu accoucher de mon
bouquin qui analyse c'est de dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait un sortons du déni
et et je dois dire que c'est très
difficile hein le déni
si quelqu'un me disait je suis certain
que ce n'est pas le cas mais que la
femme de ma vie était en train de me
tromper. Si simple de ne rien faire ?
Oui. Non. Et puis quelque part, c'est
tout à fait désagréable enfin je dis
donc accepter et je pense à notre
penser un peu au bonheur de ta femme
quand même.
Écoute, je m'en occupe.
J'espère j'espère m'en occuper pour
Mais le le problème c'est comment se
présenter devant le peuple ?
Et j'avais pensé qu'un homme comme
Emmanuel Macron, il a tout ce mec. Il a
tout.
C'est parce que tu le connais pas assez,
c'est pour ça.
Non, non, mais attends, ce que je veux
dire. Il il est beau. Attends, mais il
est beau, il est hypernésique, il
connaît tous les con.
Hyperésique, faut arrêter les conneries.
Non mais il est hypernésique. Moi je
suis hypernésique. C'est un cauchemar.
Ouais. Non mais ce que je veux dire par
là, il avait les outils puisqu'il veut
rester dans l'histoire. Mais imagine un
seul instant que au lieu de nous dire
j'ai tout fait bien nana
avec l'air le plus solennelle possible,
ils nous disent écoutez vraiment
réfléchi à la situation. Nous sommes
effectivement confrontés à quelque chose
qui est qui me dépasse, qui nous
dépasse, c'est que nous avons cru
perpétuer un progrès éternel. Il ne
l'est pas. Maintenant, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? Et plutôt que de faire un grenel
de la santé, des flics, des machins,
non. vert pour le Covid. Un numéro vert.
Oui, c'est ça. Non, mais enfin, je veux
dire,
tu es content d'avoir voté pour lui
après toutes les merdes qui nous a
pondu.
Ah ben parce que j'avais pas le choix.
Ben vote blanc.
Ouais, mais je je veux dire moi je je
suis vraiment inquiet si c'est pas les
idées d'extrême droite en elle-même dont
certaines sont abjectes pour moi, mais
c'est pas ça.
Beaucoup beaucoup.
Bon, OK, on va pas on va je sais pas où
on met le curseur si c'est à 30 ou à 70
%. Mais ce que ce que je veux dire pour
ça, non parce que la défense de la
nation c'est pas con, je vois je veux
dire c'est
normalement tout le monde devrait avoir
ce sujet-là
mais tout le monde devrait l'avoir bien.
Mais aujourd'hui, les vrais enjeux,
c'est
le constat. Et à partir de ce constat,
là il y a par contre un technooptimisme
et c'est là-dessus où où j'aimerais
qu'on qu'on échange, qui lui considère
et je me souviens d'avoir croisé Alain
Madelin euh dans les allées du pouvoir
et de la finance et qui je lui dis "Ah
bah tiens, monsieur le ministre,
qu'est-ce que vous faites ici ?" il dit
"Ben, je vais faire un un petit une
petite conférence à des financiers et
cetera." Et je lui dis "Mais qu'est-ce
que vous allez dire ?" Ça c'était il y a
5 6 ans. Ah ben je voulais dire que on
est au pied d'un évreste de révolution
technologique. Et je lui pose la
question "Et parce que vous pensez que
cet évreste va contribuer à de la
croissance ?" Il me dit "Mais c'est une
évidence."
Et c'est là c'est là le le point c'estàd
que toi tu représentes effectivement la
techno
mais que cette techno a été captée
pour donner un message d'espérance
aux communautés que nous sommes.
Je suis pas sûr. Je pense que le Bitcoin
était là pour montrer que c'était
possible. C'est un proof of concept à la
base pour moi, c'était de montrer que
c'était possible de faire quelque chose.
Alors, tout le monde est encore en train
de débattre là-dessus, sachant que son
fondateur lui-même n'a pas clairement
dit pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fait ça. Il
y a des pistes parce qu'il a lui-même
laissé des messages à droite à gauche
dans la création de Bitcoin. Mais ce
qu'il a surtout montré le le le ce qu'il
fallait démontrer, c'est que c'était
possible. Et ce n'est pour moi en fait
c'est incroyable parce qu'on a été pour
moi, on n' jamais été aussi loin
technologiquement.
Et pourtant, on n' jamais emmené autant
de valeur humaines profonde dans une
technologie. C'est ce qui m'a touché au
départ et c'est ce qui m'a surtout
touché quand j'ai commencé à le
comprendre en creusant. J'ai une petite
question pas sur quel est le constat,
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent faire pour
C'est vrai que j'ai pas tout ce recul.
analyser la politique, analyser la
finance qui était censé être au service
de l'économie, la représenter. La
politique qui pour moi a toujours été
expliquée comme on est censé représenter
des personnes qui ont des vrais
problèmes. La politique sert à ça,
représenter des problèmes et trouver des
solutions. Maintenant, c'est devenu un
métier. On doit éduquer pour devenir
politicien. Il y a des gens qui n'ont
jamais pratiqué sur le terrain et qui
disent comment on doit cadrer. Je je
découvre tout ça, la profondeur de cette
situation, de cette complexité et du
fait qu'on est tout petit, que ça va
très très vite, qu'il y a des gens qui
ne veulent rien voir, un déni, qu'il y a
d'autres personnes qui n'ont que des
solutions
et cette solution était de s'opposer. Je
me rends compte également que
malheureusement quand on se rend compte
qu'il y a une inégalité, c'est
malheureusement très souvent des
extrêmes qui viennent essayer de
rééquilibrer un peu le débat et j'en
arrive à un moment où je comprends que
la vie c'est pas un, c'est pas un c'est
pas zéro non plus, c'est un curseur.
On se retrouve dans quelque chose où on
doit jouer avec ce curseur et je pense
qu'arrêter de jouer avec ce curseur est
une erreur.
Ça c'est le constat que j'ai de mon
jeune très très jeune œil du coup et du
haut de mes 24 ans.
Non mais ça ça marche pas ici. C'estd
que 24 ans, c'est le même âge que
Raphaël. C'estàd que il y a pas de
privilège de l'âge ici.
Donc ne tombe pas dans le misérabilisme
de l'âge.
Donc ne te cache pas derrière ton âge
parce que le nous on a des Padawan qui
ont ton âge et c'est des bruts. Donc ne
commence pas à te faire écraser par les
boomers en justifant.
J'ai pas prévu de me faire écraser.
Non non, je pense pas.
Non, pas du tout.
Je pense pas. et et et même même chose
pour
mais du coup Ah mais moi je moi je suis
ouvre tes bras un petit peu.
C'est cette ouverture physique. Ah non,
j'ouvre, je ferme, j'ouvre, je ferme, je
suis comme sur un tarmac d'avion moi. Je
Owen continue.
Raphaël, qu'est-ce qu'une monnaie ? En
quelques mots, qu'est-ce qu'une monnaie
Raphaël ? Le Bitcoin n'est pas une
monnaie. Le Bitcoin c'est un billet de
monopoie. Raphaël, qu'est-ce qu'une
monnaie ? Qu'est-ce que l'on m'a appris
à l'école ?
Alors, je vais répondre. Et moi je
pourrais répondre après ou pas ?
Non non non pas pas
j'ai besoin de cette base pour en
arriver à
parce qu'on a posé cette première base
et ce premier constat financier. Moi,
j'ai une base à poser, elle est pas
encore présente.
Alors
on tu l'as très clairement dit et euh
avec
Aristote aussi
attends avec la solennité de mon âge, de
ma seigneorité. Ça ça ça marche pas non
plus hein.
Si si si si ça marche, ça marche ça
marche. Je je je confirme que le Bitcoin
c'est avant tout une blockchain.
Je suis aujourd'hui certain,
contrairement à ce que j'ai dit le 4
mars devant ces ces caméras que la
blockchain sera et on va même pas s'en
s'en rendre compte sera dans les 10 15
ans qui viennent. aussi banal que
l'internet.
OK. Bien.
Donc ça mais coule pas vrai carré. Non
non mais
j'en attendais pas vraiment moins du
personnage.
Non non mais non mais
attends attends attends attends je je
j'y viens.
J'ai parfaitement compris que pour que
ces blockchains soient vivantes actives
répondent à leur mission
qu'effectivement il y avait une
rémunération en bon point. Quand j'étais
à l'école, j'avais des bons points et en
et avec 10 bons points, j'avais une
image et avec 10 images, j'avais un
satisfait.
D'ailleurs, d'ailleurs, c'est un
scandale éducatif de de faire des
Tu l'appelles, attends, tu l'appelles
aujourd'hui un jeton, un coin, un token.
Très bien.
Une monnaie.
Alors
que dans la communauté
qui utilise cette blockchain et plus la
communauté est large, plus ce jeton
prend de la valeur. Clair
vrai aussi sur sa valorisation mais
c'est pas ma question.
D'accord.
Maintenant, une monnaie,
c'est trois choses.
Ah,
c'est un outil d'échange,
c'est une réserve de valeur
et c'est l'émanation d'une souveraineté.
Ou là ou là, attention, il a dit des
trucs sur la table.
Ah oui, parce qu'Aistote en tout cas
n'avait pas les mêmes mots.
D'accord.
Quel mot ? un étalon de valeur.
Alors,
le Bitcoin est l'étalon des
cryptomonnaies. Le Bitcoin est un
instrument d'échange de communication
financière. Je
mal
le Bitcoin répond à toutes les fonctions
qui ont été préalablement citées, sauf
cette dernière.
Top top top. Malgré malgré sur l'état
régalen. Bien sûr. Attends, attends.
Alors, malgré tout le respect que j'ai
pour Aristote,
l'étalon n'est pas la monnaie. L'étalon
n'est pas la monnaie. La monnaie est un
outil d'échange. C'est une réserve de
valeur et c'est l'émanation d'une
souveraineté.
Est-ce que je peux mettre un peu de sel
dans votre plat là ?
Oui. Oui. Salon. Salon.
La monnaie, c'est de la calorie stockée.
OK. L'or l'or c'est de la calorie
stockée.
Euh si tu si tu fais référence et tu
réponds
à l'exploitation.
Ouais. Donc aller chercher de l'or au
départ quand on était à quatre pattes et
à se battre avec des coups de battant,
ça demandait du temps. Donc du temps
c'est de l'argent et donc en gros c'est
de la calorie pour pour aller chercher
l'or. Et donc la calorie se stock dans
l'or parce que les gens savent que c'est
difficile pour aller chercher l'or.
La cryptoonnaie plus les gens minent
plus c'est difficile plus il faut de la
calorie énergétique pour sortir du
Bitcoin. On est d'accord Owen ?
Tout à fait. Bon, je vous laisse
continuer. Allez-y.
Alors alors déjà
donc attends attendsends donc attends
mais il il faut il faut qu'on soit bien
d'accord que euh
le père Aristote là il se gour il se
gourt dans la mesure où cet outil
qui est
échange
stockage de valeur ou l'émanation
il a toujours un étalon et que l'étalon
du Bitcoin c'est la techn
c'est c'est la blockchain chaîne, c'est
la robustesse de la blockchain. Et là,
je rends grâce à à Jérémie dont je suis
sûr qu'il est là, euh qui qui a un
projet fantastique qui s'appelle Rétribe
de de de paiement justement avec une
vocation
une vocation, on va dire presque
sociale. OK. et et qui me fait le
l'honneur de me demander de réfléchir à
une éthique financière sur ces
problématiques et cetera. Et
effectivement, le point c'est un point
d'étalon. Or,
l'étalon ne fait pas la monnaie.
Et c'est de ce point de vue-là que je
dis, je peux comprendre que dans la
communauté
Bitcoin,
les les que ce soi les mineurs, pas les
mineurs et cetera
et et donner une valeur avec un marché
de l'offre et de la demande très clair.
Bon, Christine la garde en fait, elle se
protège hein,
c'est un postulat. Ce n'est plus une
position, ce n'est plus et puis elle est
bien trop intelligente, elle a beaucoup
trop de recul pour croire tout ce
qu'elle dit. Et là, on a abordé que le
Bitcoin n'est pas une monnaie parce
qu'elle en a sorti quelques-unes qui
peuvent être mis en cause.
Absolument. Mais donc un actif peut être
une monnaie. Donc dès lors que dès lors
qu'elle dit que le Bitcoin est un actif,
en fait cet actif peut devenir un outil
d'échange de stockage de valeur et
exprimer la souveraineté d'une
blockchain qui se veut par nature
euh décentralisé apporter plus de
confiance qu'un acteur centralisé. C'est
sûr que sur la définition de la monnaie,
si on a cette souveraineté, tout va
dépendre de qui on met derrière en fait.
La souveraineté, c'est le lien de
confiance.
Et ce lien de confiance, trop longtemps
abusé,
ouais. fait que maintenant il y a un
moyen de se référer à un algorithme.
Algorithme qui ne prend plus en compte
la couleur de peau, le sexe,
la situation géographique, les les idées
politiques, la culture, algorithme qui
considère toute personne sur cette
planète comme un être et lui donnant les
mêmes droits et lui offrant les mêmes
services. En parallèle de ça, sur un
socle technologique robuste à souhait.
Ouais. antifragile.
Ouais.
Qui plus il perdure dans le temps, plus
est solide.
Bien sûr. Quoi ? Antifragile,
plus on va aller le challenger, plus on
va aller le tester, plus il va faire de
l'incrémentation, il va s'endurcir.
Il va s'endurcir. La façon dont l'être
humain a progressé jusqu'à présent
d'ailleurs, l'évolution.
Et on en est arrivé à une situation où
l'up time de Bitcoin, donc son temps de
fonctionnement sur 1 an en pourcentage
est supérieur à celui de Google. C'est
une boule de neige lancée en haut d'une
montagne en 2008.
Et pourtant au niveau technologique, il
y a d'autres cryptomonnaies, il y a
d'autres solutions moins coûteuses, plus
rapide. Mais Bitcoin est un mur en béton
armé. Bitcoin a été fondé sur bien plus
qu'une technologie. Il a été fondé sur
des idées profondes et un besoin un
besoin pour certaines personnes qui se
voient fermer la porte de la
centralisation et je n'ai rien contre.
On peut avoir confiance en sa banque, on
peut avoir confiance en certaines
entreprises, on peut avoir confiance en
ses prestataires. Par contre, on ne doit
pas nous obliger à passer par des
acteurs centralisés sans solution bis,
sans autres portes ouvertes. Bitcoin ne
vous fermera jamais la porte. Et ça
c'est incroyable. Et ça ça offre
beaucoup de visibilité. Et là où c'était
le premier message envoyé par Bitcoin,
on en a décliné des outils, des usages
et des créations plus folles les unes
que les autres pour répondre à des
problèmes existants et peut-être même
des problèmes qui n'existent pas encore.
Moi ce qui me gêne profondément, c'est
que j'ai l'impression qu'on attend de la
décentralisation deux choses. Déjà pour
beaucoup de gens qu'elle tuent la
centralisation, je ne suis pas d'accord.
Il faut arrêter de penser que quelque
chose de nouveau se doit de tuer ce
qu'il y avait avant. C'est une
évolution. On va faire un constat, on va
enlever certaines choses inutiles qui
existaient avant, on va créer certaines
choses utiles avec cette nouvelle
technologie et on va en faire une
hybridation utile en essayant d'utiliser
les avantages des deux technologies.
1 + 1 = 2 et pas un doit tuer un pour
qu'il ne reste qu'un à la fin. Je ne
pense pas comme ça. C'est le postulat de
certains même dans la blockchain et dans
les cryptonnaies.
La deuxième chose, c'est que ce soit
toujours ouvert parce qu'encore une
fois, on dit blockchain mais je vais
reprendre le parallèle de tout à
l'heure. On dit internet. On peut faire
tout et n'importe quoi avec internet.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des blockchains
comme Bitcoin public porteuse de valeur.
Il y a d'autres blockchains qui
s'apparentent plus à des monnaies
numériques qui sont là pour avoir des
avantages technologiques mais qui n'ont
pas ce but profond d'envoyer ce message
humain. Et il y en a d'autres qui sont
d'ailleurs très utiles mais sans porter
toutes ces valeurs. Moi, la question que
j'ai envie de poser à la finance
traditionnelle
ou du moins à cette finance que je suis
encore en train de découvrir, c'est
factuellement quelle a été l'action
quelle est l'action mécanique
mathématique qui vient biaiser ce
système ? Et là, j'aurai la base pour
pouvoir apporter ma réponse. Je pense si
je ne me trompe pas et que j'ai bien
ciblé.
Alors,
quelle est l'action une une pas j'ai
besoin d'une action et pas d'un concept
sinon je ne peux non non je je je vais
je vais te répondre. Je vais te
répondre.
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est que
historiquement
euh l'économie était au service de
l'homme. OK. Et que la finance était au
service de l'économie.
Bien.
Euh, on en fait d'ailleurs le la
déclaration d'une d'une fondation que
l'on souhaite créer avec
pas mal de tes copains au sens de de de
cette communauté
en se disant qu'il y a peut-être
justement moyen de mettre un peu plus
d'éthique dans la finance
dans Attends, attends. Mais non, mais me
me casse pas mon parfaitement là où je
veux. Non, non, mais me casse me casse
pas mon espérance. Après, je
c'est de dire puisqu'il y a justement
un un contrôle des uns autres, hein. Euh
et comme l'a dit et comme je l'ai
découvert hier, une phrase de de la part
d'un de tes camarades de jeu, c'est
la loi, c'est le code.
Code is low,
hein. Code is low. Ce qui veut dire que
euh et et quand j'ai découvert ça, là,
je me suis retrouvé devant un gouffre de
perplexité dans la mesure où la loi
était euh avec ses yeux bordés, son
glève et sa balance était quelque chose
qui était
qui était hors hors de l'humanité, hors
du monde, hors de la matérialité. Donc
le fait d'encapsuler
la loi et le code,
c'était pas hors de l'humanité la loi.
C'est ça le problème. C'est le relicat
entre la loi et la justice. Elle était
pas totalement impartiale ou alors dans
certains moments, selon certains angles
de vue et circonstances, l'algorithme
lui est impartial.
Attends, attends, j'ai j'ai pas fini ma
réponse.
L'algorithme est impartial.
de de sa constitution le euh donc
pendant des millénaires et y compris
pendant cette période
glorieuse où le progrès
de de Victor Hugo puisque je l'ai cité a
été une réalité. La finance était au
service de l'économie qui était
elle-même au service de l'homme.
Aujourd'hui, depuis 40 ans, dans ce
processus de grande régression,
l'homme est au service de l'économie qui
est elle-même exclusivement au service
de la finance.
O Enwen, je peux prendre la parole ?
Tu tu vois le point ? Je pense que j'ai
répondu.
On est là. Je je c'est ça mais je
voulais savoir quel est cet abut
financièrement. Qu'est-ce qui est fait ?
Qu'est-ce qui vient biaiser cette
économie factuellement
? C'est simplement que au lieu
normalement la la finance le circuit
sanguin d'un corps. Normalement
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait pour dynamiser
ce corps ou comment est-ce qu'on y
allait ? Comment la finance allait aider
l'économie à l'époque où c'était ça ?
Ah mais parce que elle répondait au
besoins économiques qui répondait au
besoins humains.
D'accord. Un exemple factuel. Comment
un besoin factuel ? Je je voulais créer
des boulangeries industrielles
dans le dans en Bourgogne. J'avais
besoin de finances pour créer des fours,
des pétrins et cetera. Et la finance
mettait en relation de l'épargne
des autorités pour mettre à la
disposition les moyens économi les
moyens financiers
de réaliser sa mission économique.
Ça c'était simple. Ça ça développait.
OK, juste un chiffre juste un chiffre
pour pour C'était bio juste un chiffre
Juste un chiffre qui est
euh qui illustre la folie dans laquelle
nous sommes. Le 10 novembre de dernier,
c'est hier, la planète entière a produit
entre 200 et 250 milliards de dollars de
biens et de services.
dans la même journée d'hier,
de combien ont été les échanges
financiers ? Il y a il y a aucun chiffre
là-dessus. Mais moi,
les échanges financiers quoi ? Des
différentes places boursières, vololum.
Non, non, non. Tout tous les échanges
financiers, place les les places
financières sur les matières premières,
sur les options, sur tous les flux
financiers de la journée d'hier
mais beaucoup plus. Oui, mais dans
quelle proportion ? C'est expri.
Il faut donner ses sources quand même.
C'est 50 fois plus,
c'est 10000 milliards hier.
OK. Donc ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut
dire que plutôt que de chercher à
construire des ponts, des machins, des
des des médoc pour ceux qui souffrent,
des aliments, des chaussures, des
ascenseurs, des contrats d'assurance et
cetera. Il y a aujourd'hui une finance
qui de sur croix s fortement
mathématisé. Oui. Donc elle séduit les
esprits qui sont capables de réfléchir
de façon conceptuelle.
OK ? Et vous avez aujourd'hui un univers
dont moi je représente une toute petite
partie puisque je n'ai jamais fait de
trading de ma vie et cetera. Moi,
j'accompagne des entrepreneurs pour
trouver des solutions au financement de
leurs exploitations.
Du concret.
Du concret. D'accord. qui donne à manger
aux gens et qui payent les les
cotisations et nous fournissons des
outils de la même façon dans la
cryptoonnaie pour c'est la même
absolument et et c'est pour ça que je
t'ai dit tout à l'heure, je suis
convaincu que la blockchain va rentrer
dedans.
Après se pose le problème. Est-ce que
cela va permettre ou non
de réduire l'importance de la finance ?
C'est le point où je veux aller mais j'y
suis même pas encore parce que du coup
on a eu un point factuel sur comment la
finance servait proprement et de façon
bio l'économie.
Ouais.
On veut un exemple de comment la finance
dessert l'économie et donc l'homme.
Aujourd'hui, un exemple très simple,
factuel.
Et ben un exemple très simple, c'est que
le même industriel, mon cher Patrick, si
vous me regardez ce si tu me regardes ce
soir, euh qui a n usine 1500 employés et
cetera.
dans la tôlerie, il ne peut pas dégager
les 12 à 15 % que le que la finance
exige de lui. Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il
fait ? Il s'endettete de façon
euh c'est pas cher de s'endetter en
plus. C'est pas cher, c'est même
gratuit. On peut gagner de l'argent
s'endou. Ouis. Oui. Mais ça c'est
totalement artificiel. Voilà, c'est la
façon dont la finance aujourd'hui n'est
nature tout
tout ce qui a été bio, tout ce qui a été
sain et tout ce qui a été posé.
Absolument. Mais mais dans des
proportion. Et c'est là mon angoisse.
Mais quand je dis mon angoisse, c'est
que réellement elle me prend le plexus.
c'est de dire moi qui suis dans dans le
comment dirais-je dans le le noyau euh
dans dans le réacteur hein étant donné
que je suis dans le réacteur je vois et
quand je dis à des gens qui rêvent d'un
fond souverain on en a un en France ça
s'appelle la BPI
et ben la BPI me dit "Ah non non non non
euh ta société de deux choses l'une,
soit elle se délocalise, c'est pas ce
qu'ils me disent mais c'est la
traduction de ce qu'ils me disent. que
fait hein
que tu en fais
enfin que j'en fais moi hein. Ça ça ça
engage moi mais ça engage mon copain
Patrick parce que effectivement à partir
du moment où ils me disent "Ah oui mais
si on investit en fond propre à hauteur
de 6 ou 8 % ce qui serait déjà énorme on
va dire 6 Bruxelles va nous tomber
dessus parce que ce ne sont pas et
cetera et cetera." Bon, donc on est on
est dans un on est dans un écosystème et
c'est là où il m'inquiète, c'est que
l'on oublie que à la base de tous les
écosystèmes, c'est les hommes. Nous
sommes cinq dans ce sur ce plateau,
sept il y en a deux derrière
et il y en a deux derrière. Donc nous
sommes sept dans ce dans dans ce dans
cette sphère. Nous sommes des êtres
humains et nous devons
rendre des comptes
à tous nos partenaires.
C'est c'est sur cette base que je vais
en arriver à un premier élément de
réflexion. J'ai même pas envie de dire
réponse parce qu'il y en a des
réflexions à avoir et mais très
clairement en fait et c'est comme ça que
c'est vu par le très jeune œil du monde
de la cryptomonnaie.
Parle gentiment au vieux. D'accord. le
très jeune œil parce que c'est une
technologie qui a 13 ans. On n'est même
plus là à regarder. Dans dans ma tête,
je suis plus jeune que lui hein. Mais ça
c'est un c'est un autre point.
Bon ça ça reste à prouver.
Si si si. La communauté crypto dirait
qu'il y a un des gros problèmes. C'est
ça s'apparente plus ou moins la dette de
près ou de loin.
Ouais
déjà la dette je n'ai pas l'impression
et encore une fois je le découvre que la
dette soit tout le temps négative ou
tout le temps positive. Il y a également
différentes façons et c'est également ce
qu'on va en faire. Si c'est pour qu'elle
soit captée finalement très rapidement
par un enton noir qui a été placé ici
par des esprits capables de
conceptualiser la finance qui viennent
absorber un système déjà bien rodé et
que ça nous arrange bien qu'on envoie du
sable en haut de l'entonoir car on sait
où il termine, on en arrive dans la même
chose.
Le sable c'est les injections de
liquidité.
C'est ça. Le sable c'est les injections
de liquidité. Encore une fois comment
cette liquidité injectée ? Comment
est-ce qu'elle est créée ? J'ai eu j'ai
vu passer un truc sur Twitter comme quoi
on
liquidité basée sur de la dette. C'est
ça les liquidité basée sur de la dette
et injectée encore et encore. Et c'est
pas enfin c'est l'un des problèmes. On
peut pas résumer le problème à ça. J'ai
vu passer un truc sur Twitter fou et
très intéressant et même très drôle.
C'estes deux personnes qui discutent et
il y en a une qui dit "Mais ta
cryptomonnaie elle vaut rien."
Et il dit "Mais pourquoi elle vaut rien
ma cryptomonnaie ?" Il fait parce que la
supply le nombre de cryptomonnaes émises
peut-être modifié quand on veut.
Quelqu'un peut faire de l'émission de ta
cryptomonnaie exnilo rajouter un
chiffre, il peut et puis il dit "Mais
non, tu dis des bêtises en fait c'est
créé intelligemment au prata d'une règle
intelligente." Il fait "Oui, mais ce
n'est pas capé." Et donc bah 50 % ou 40
% de la cryptomonnaie de ta propre
cryptomonnaie a été créée dans les
derniers mois. Viens pas me dire que
c'est sérieux, viens pas me dire que
c'est stable, viens pas me dire que
c'est la l'économie réelle de l'usage
réel de ta blockchain qui a demandé
cette émission.
C'est pas une cryptomonnaie ça, c'est le
dollar américain. 40 % d'émission de la
supply sur moins de 6 mois, c'est le
dollar américain. Voilà. Alors,
naturellement, on peut pas résumer une
émission monétaire à de enfin de la à
l'inflation tout de suite, mais 40 % de
la supply. Voilà le premier élément de
réponse de Bitcoin. Beaucoup de gens
parlent de sa décentralisation et ils
ont raison. Son socle technologique
incroyable, c'est il y a énormément de
choses merveilleuses à dire sur le
Bitcoin. Mais on pourrait le résumer en
une seule phrase si on m'obligeait
quelques caractères. Il n'y en aura que
21 millions.
Alors je je
c'est un premier élément de réponse.
Ouais. Je je je rebondis parce que
je je considère que aujourd'hui
intrinsèquement
le dollar ne vaut rien.
Ah ça fait déjà un point. Le dollar ne
vaut rien.
Ça, je suis pas d'accord.
Top top. Attends. Intrinsèquement.
C'est-à-dire que les souvenons-nous
valeur d'échange très forte, valeur de
réserve, c'est celle-là à laquelle je je
je fais référence et la souveraineté.
Par contre, donc en en terme de réserve
de valeur, c'est zéro. Par contre, elle
est frappée
par le pays qui reste aujourd'hui le
plus puissant du monde. La première
armée du monde. La première armée du
monde et celle qui verrouille
tout ce qui est contrat, norme, standard
et cetera.
Mais c'est contradictoire avec les mots
utilisés préalablement. Je sais
parce que parce que globalement, si j'ai
bien compris, une monnaie est censée
être censée souverain. Et donc le
souverain dans le dans le cas du dollar,
c'est une entité centralisée. Et à ce
moment-là, si c'est une personne qui
peut nous garantir sa valeur, même s'il
en imprime encore et encore, bah le
dollar est censé valoir quelque chose.
Donc je me retrouve pas dans les deux
discours que vous enfin que tu m'as
donné du coup. Alors si parce que
celui qui aujourd'hui se promène dans
les dans les rues de Hil à a envie d'un
bol de riz et s'il lui reste un billet
euh froissé de 1 dollar,
il va trouver quelqu'un qui va lui
donner un bol de riz. À partir de là,
bon,
ça a une valeur.
Donc ça a une valeur. Donc ça a une
valeur. Mais je dis que intrinsèquement
compte tenu de de l'émission monétaire
de ce papier, d'accord,
sa valeur est devenue d'ailleurs par
rapport à l'or dont le marché est
complètement cadennaassé depuis 50 ans.
Complètement cadenassé. la vraie valeur
de l'or. Si ça devait être un open
market, il y a eu des panflets qui ont
circulé dans les années 2007 à Wall
Street, on serait entre 10 et 20000
dollars lonce.
OK. Bon, mais par rapport à un marché
cannassé, le dollar lance là
actuellement non ? On est à combien
lance ? Oui. 2000 dollars ou un truc
comme ça par rapport alors le dollar a
perdu 98 % de sa valeur. J'étais
pourtant bien aligné à un moment.
Oui. Non mais non mais attends non mais
quand même eu un bout de papier qui a
dit bon
non mais attends attends
après ils ont dit vous ramenez l'or
parce que c'est interdit. Bon donc
comme les Bitcoin dans certains pays,
que je peux comme le Bitcoin dans
certains pays
par contre par contre je pense que nous
sommes d'accord sur un certain nombre de
choses. Moi, j'ai une angoisse,
une angoisse, une question.
Kanes
a eu tort sur pas mal de choses
mais il a eu raison sur une chose, c'est
notre préférence à tous pour la
liquidité dans certains moments. Bon
oui, souviens-toi de mon constat, c'est
que nous sommes après 40 ans d'une
grande régression
de deux choses. lune. Soit les gens
continuent à se dire "Mais dans le fond,
on vit de la dette mais c'est relaxe,
c'est cool hein, on on continue
d'émettre de la dette et cetera." Alors
là, je dis solennellement,
ne rêvons pas. Chaque fois qu'il y a eu
humainement trop de dettes, on assiste à
un effondrement du système. Et dans ce
cas-là, il y a la dimension sociale et
humaine qui me me qui est mon obsession.
Comme je le je le dis dans mon livre,
c'est cette notion de décrochage humain,
hein. Tu sais quand un avion décroche,
c'est fini.
Il perd sa portance.
D'accord.
Il manque de vitesse, hein.
Manque de vitesse.
Manque de vitesse. Donc bon,
on parlera de la ville la vitesse de
circulation de la monnaie après.
Ah bah justement, elle s'est effondrée,
c'est c'est normal compte tenu de et
cetera. Mais le le le point c'est à ce
moment-là,
il va y avoir les vieux réflexes de
préférence pour la liquidité.
Du son et du trébuchon.
La liquidité. Donc oui, non.
Normalement, c'est le sonor et le
trébon. Donc
on est Oui, mais attends attends, c'est
c'est c'est très important pour ta
communauté.
Pas tbéchant de cette liquidité. Je
pense pas he.
Laisse terminer papier.
Pardon. Pardon.
c'est que aujourd'hui euh je vois bien
toute la comment dirais-je toute la
robustesse. C'est le mot que tu as
utilisé
du Bitcoin comme étant leader de
la confiance
de de la confiance dans les
cryptoonnaies. Très bien.
D'après
Oui, mais ça y est. Maintenant, j'ai
compris pourquoi j'ai compris. C'est
parce qu'il y a une communauté qui est
tellement large qu'effectivement dans
cette communauté, tu as suffisamment de
de beeder et de asker pour que tout ça
s'équilibre par rapport à un certain
prix
de parilleurs et de demandeurs.
Oui.
et et et on va on va répondre à la
première question que tu avais eu, c'est
que effectivement on retrouve quand même
des réflexe
polluant, c'est que il y a quand même
une poignée, je sais pas si c'est 2 %
mais il y a une poignée de détenteur de
cette monnaie. Il des reçu à briser. Il
est reçu à briser tout de suite. Donne
donne la parole au bébé nageur. Vas-y.
Alors, il y a des gros détenteurs de
Bitcoin et le problème d'un monde dans
lequel on veut que chacun puisse prendre
ses propres responsabilités, que chacun
puisse être sa propre banque, que chacun
puisse prendre ses propres décisions
sans aucune censure, et bien on doit
accepter que chacun puisse faire ses
propres bêtises. Et par définition, on
se doit d'accepter aussi que quelqu'un
peut aujourd'hui comprendre bien avant
les autres que le Bitcoin est une vraie
porte de sortie bien plus robiste, bien
plus robuste pardon que certains
concepts avec lesquels on joue
d'alchimie et de mélange et donc
quelqu'un prenne beaucoup de place. Ça
déjà, il faut être capable de l'accepter
même si finalement ça ne fera que
recréer la même chose. Mais quand on dit
2 % des adresses détiennent tous les
Bitcoin, déjà il y a une bonne grosse
adresse du créateur de Bitcoin lui-même.
Cinq adresses. D'ailleurs, 50000 Bitcoin
par adresse, ils n'ont jamais bougé. La
bonne nouvelle de ce réseau, c'est que
contrairement aux fortunes de ce monde
qui détiennent les fonds que nous avons,
là c'est totalement transparent. On sort
un smartphone, n'importe quel être
humain avec internet en plein milieu de
l'Afrique, au Japon, en Australie, où
qu'il soit dans cette planète, on peut
voir où sont les Bitcoin. C'est
pseudonyme, on ne sait pas qui est
derrière mais on peut la voir cette
supply, on peut la comprendre. C'est
très dur de comprendre la supply de
l'euro et du dollar en je m'en rends
compte. Je je ne comprends pas, je ne
sais pas, c'est pas clair, ça prend du
temps, il y a des délais sur Bitcoin,
c'est instantané. On sait où ils sont et
on sait qui les a. Et ensuite une grosse
partie de ces 2 % d'adress c'est pas si
ça mais on s'est compris les
cryptomonnaies le sont. Et quand on dit
que 2 % des adresses détiennent la
plupart des Bitcoin, la plupart de ces
adresses sont des adresses d'exchange,
des établissements qui proposent aux
gens d'acheter et de vendre. C'est un
peu comme si on disait une grosse partie
des actions d'une entreprise sont gérées
par telle bourse à Paris ou au Nasdaq.
C'est normal, elles appartiennent à
différentes personnes bien qu'elles soi
détenu sur un seul endroit. Donc c'est
une vraie idée reçue.
Raphaël
alors euh
je je suis pas capable de de de de
répondre à ça.
Je le conçois pour le coup. Je je suis
absolum et
il y a malgré tout dans ces 2 % quelques
grosses personnalités qui détiennent
beaucoup et donc c'est pas totalement
vrai.
Quelques grosses institutions
américaines aussi. D'abord pour pour
répondre
pour répondre à ton internaute
euh il faut savoir une chose plus une
communauté
de de détenteur d'un actif et ou d'une
monnaie est large,
plus un petit nombre peut faire
jouer cette valeur.
C'est le cas du diamant alors qu'il y a
très peu de détenteurs.
Absolument. Alors ça marche dans les
c'est c'est l'exemple de beaucoup de
patrons qui disent "Ah oui, mais je vais
être dilué." Pas problème d'argent, mais
c'est un problème de pouvoir, de
gouvernance et autres. Je dis écoutez,
souvenez-vous que la famille Ford a eu
quand même les destinées du groupe Ford
entre les mains pendant la moitié de
l'existence de cette société
avec seulement 4 % de détention des
titres. C'est-à-dire que pour une raison
très simple, c'est que quand on crée
l'assemblée physique des détenteurs, euh
les 4 % représente 50 % des présents.
Oui. Des actions préférentielles.
D'accord. Bon, donc
en fait, il y a toujours à partir du
moment où on financiarise une approche
un un nombre des happy few qui peuvent
manipuler
la valeur. Ça c'est une loi éternelle.
Et si un musque avec son influence a
envie de dire je vends et donc fait
paniquer les gens. Là où je suis
d'accord quand les gens disent Bitcoin
n'est pas une monnaie, je suis pas
d'accord avec l'approche mais Bitcoin
n'a pas de valeur. Non il n'a pas de
valeur régulée. Il a une vraie valeur
bio.
On s'énerve pas. On s'énerve pas. Alors
la régulation la régulation des
cryptomonnaies.
Oui.
Comment ça se passe ? Parce que en
étudiant le sujet depuis des années, on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup de je reprends l'expression de
la communauté Bitcoin, beaucoup de
marchands de tapis pour reprendre leur
expression
et des gens en fait qui brassent
beaucoup d'air chaud, qui brassent du
vent, qui sont plus des formateurs en
conscience professionnelle, personnelle
qu'autre chose, du moins des des bons
orateurs, mais derrière il y a pas
grand-chose. Donc en terme de
régulation, en terme de contrôle, en
terme de surveillance pour protéger les
gens qui se placent sur les
cryptoonnaies, on en est où ? Alors
battez-vous pour prendre un là pour coup
j'ai la réponse factuelle de l'évement
de la régulation des cryptonnaies en
France. avant que tu ne la donnes de
manière à ne pas polluer ma propre
réponse
sur le Bitcoin bureau. Ni encore
en fait la perception que j'ai donc je
rappelle je rappelle que je suis
soucieux et je me dis par rapport à
toutes les solutions qui permettraient
de je crois dans la blockchain et donc
de façon induite dans ces
crypts/monnais.
OK. Bien.
Non non mais bon parce que parce qu'en
fait ça enfin on peut en débattre
jusqu'à clairement
mais moi mais moi mon point il est pas
là c'est que pour que ça devienne
vraiment un outil d'échange
qui est donc la première fonction de la
monnaie il ne faut pas qu'il y ait de
volatilité
exagérée
et donc
elle est là la volatilité du Bitcoin
elle est dans ma montre Oui, mais le le
le problème c'est que si je il est à
combien le Bitcoin aujourd'hui ? 50 60
60000 dollars plus 60000 dollars 65
D'accord. Bah ça fait 15 % de moins donc
ça fait 50
power.
D'accord. Donc euh
admettons que euh
je je je sois beaucoup plus riche que
les gens ne pensent que je le suis et
que je puisse vous offrir ou t'offrir à
toi un Bitcoin. Yes ! 65000 balles, tu
peux commencer à à rêver d'une belle
bagnole, voire d'un bateau, voire même
d'un petit avion, voire de enfin bon,
un peu une maison, un toit, pas une
passerie énergétique, des trucs comme ça
quoi.
Absolument.
Des trucs pour regarder l'avenir.
D'accord.
Et je te le donne aujourd'hui le 11
novembre
2021.
tu le stockes dans ton wallet machin et
cetera et tu te le portefeuille et tu te
dis bah euh moi je vais euh euh voilà
pour mon anniversaire qui je crois est
au mois de mai.
Tout à fait
d'accord. Euh
c'est quoi le nom de sa copine ?
Effrayant.
C'est euh
et au mois de mai, soit tu pourras te
payer deux bateaux ou un bateau plus une
piscine plus un machin plus un truc,
l'isolation de ta maison d'abord.
D'accord.
Soit soit peut-être la moitié ou ou le
quart. Donc en fait, on en fait je suis
convaincu d'une chose, c'est qu'il y a
une énorme bienveillance de tous ceux
qui travaillent sur la blockchain,
enfin de ceux que j'ai rencontré.
Oui, voilà. Non, non, ils existent,
attention. de ce que j'ai rencontré,
d'accord, et que cette bienveillance
fait que il travaille à un système qui,
au-delà d'être un un un outil financier
est un outil de gouvernance.
Tout à fait,
hein, dans une certaine communauté.
Bien. Et je suis très sensible à ça,
très sensible. Le seul problème, c'est
que dès lors que ça devient un outil
d'échange,
cette décentralisation
lui nuit. Car tant qu'il vous n'aurez
pas quelqu'un qui sera capable de gérer
ce que j'appelle dans mon jaron,
ça existe déjà.
Un carnet d'ordre.
Ça existe déjà alors
de façon décentralisée et de façon
beaucoup plus stable puisqu'on peut
l'adosser à la valeur qu'on veut à
travers des stable coin décentralisés.
J'insiste bien. Ce qu'il faut
comprendre, c'est que la volatilité du
Bitcoin,
stable coin, c'est des des coins basés
sur
adossé à d'autres actifs plus stables.
Ça peut être l'or, ça peut être le
dollar, ça peut être l'euro, n'importe
quoi que l'on considère comme plus
stable. On va créer une cryptomonnaie
dont la valeur va osiller à 1 % près à
cette valeur plus stable.
Donc c'est un panier de monnaie.
C'est un panier de monnaie. Et après, je
donnerai un exemple d'un stable coin
décentralisé qui est bel et bien aligné
au dollar mais absolument pas baqué par
le dollar. Absolument pas.
Tu peux préciser ?
Back, je vais le préciser. Mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que la volatilité des
cryptonnaies que l'on peut pointer du
doigt et montrer, elle fait partie de
jeunes cycles naissants de technologie.
On dit le Bitcoin est très volatile, il
est de moins en moins.
Il a pas tort, il
il est de moins en moins. Si on regarde
à l'échelle logarithmique,
le Bitcoin était passé de quelques
centimes à 12 €. C'était phénoménal le
pourcentage. Puis de 12 à 200 puis de
200 il avait tapé les 20000. De 20000 à
60000 aujourd'hui. C'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement volatile si on compare à la
finance que l'on étudie encore tous les
jours et à ce que l'on peut considérer
comme monnaie. Mais ça va non seulement
se stabiliser en fonction des volumes et
en fonction de l'adoption. Rappelons que
les cryptonnaies c'est 3000 milliards de
dollars. Soit
un seul scandale de la finance
traditionnelle, les Pandora Paper,
représente cinq fois plus que
l'intégralité de toutes les
cryptoonnaies aujourd'hui en
circulation. On n'est même pas sur de
l'embryon. On n'est même pas sur de
l'embryon. Et pourtant d'une résilience
forte,
un modèle qui se développe
naturellement, qui a eu ses failles mais
qui a été corrigé par la communauté. Un
modèle où personne ne veut être
l'actionnaire majoritaire. Parce qu'une
personne qui deviendrait actionnaire
majoritaire de Bitcoin en ayant 51 % de
la puissance de calcul parce que c'est
comme ça que fonctionne le Bitcoin,
quelqu'un qui a donc 51 % des
ordinateurs de la planète qui sécurisent
son réseau, c'est quelqu'un qui serait
obligé de le faire en toute
transparence. On pourrait le voir. Et si
quelqu'un arrive à abuser de cette
puissance pour par exemple émettre de
nouveaux Bitcoin ou faire attends
attends, je peux je peux t'arrêter. Tu
es en train de décrire un réseau de
zombie là ou bien ?
Pas du tout. C'estàd que moi si par
exemple
oui
je reprenais quelques travers et que je
me disais que tous les PC qu'il y a dans
mon immeuble et de mon quartier j'allais
les vérer pour qu'ils travaillent pour
moi.
Veroler véroler.
Si moi je dis je vais faire miner les
autres sans leur accord.
OK. Donc on arrive on imagine quelqu'un
qui arrive à prendre une très grosse
puissance de calcul, un contrôle bien ou
malveillant, il arrive à prendre une
très très grosse puissance de calcul. et
bien cette personne n'aurait aucun
intérêt à monter à 51 % de ce réseau. 51
% permettrait de faire quoi ? Ça me
permettrait de dépenser un Bitcoin et de
dire au réseau, "Non, non, t'inquiète,
je je l'ai pas dépensé, je peux le
dépenser deux fois." La double dépense.
C'est ce qui fait très très peur dans le
monde du Bitcoin. Parce que si on arrive
à dépenser deux fois la même monnaie, ça
y est, on en est revenu à des sacrés
travers.
Ah ben c'est fini.
Quit à en créé des nouveaux. Voilà,
c'est fini. Et bien à ce moment-là déjà,
j'aurais déployé une énergie folle he
quand on sait que Facebook, Amazon,
Google tous réunis, ils auraient moins
de 2 ou 3 % de la puissance parce que
c'est une puissance bien spécifique.
Donc c'est techniquement pas faisable.
Mais imaginons que tu sois réellement
excellent et que tu contrôles tellement
de puissance informatique,
je travaille à la NSA.
La NSA
n'aurait aucun intérêt à le faire déjà
parce que même avec toute cette
puissance, elle n'y serait pas. C'est un
matériel informatique bien précis. Ah
non, j'en suis certain. Je crois que en
en comptant les plus gros
cybercalculateurs de la planète, on
arrive à 1 ou 2 %, c'est une puissance
en SHA 256 pour être précis et donc une
puissance de calcul que du matériel
informatique traditionnel, téléphone ou
ordinateur basique aujourd'hui ne peut
pas fournir de la même façon.
En imaginant que quelqu'un arrive à
avoir 51 % à la seconde où il y a une
double dépense. C'est un réseau qui est
tellement observé, qui est tellement
transparent que même si on ne sait pas
qui est derrière une adresse, si
quelqu'un arrive à dépenser deux fois le
même Bitcoin, on le voit.
Juste une question qui n'a rien à voir.
Tu penses qu'on peut péter de la ES 256
ou pas ?
en en rentrant tous les concepts
d'informatique quantique, en rentrant
toutes les technologies qu'on peut avoir
ou en nous basant clairement sur la
puissance informatique d'un d'un bruit
de force actuellement en circulation. Je
je manque de je manque de recul sur ça
pour pouvoir répondre.
Donc revenons à ma question initiale. La
réglement juste juste il me reste une
toute petite phrase pour bloquer ça.
C'est le seul modèle où devenir
l'actionnaire majoritaire n'est pas
rentable car si on arrive à déployer la
puissance nécessaire, ça coûterait des
des c'est énergétiquement et
financièrement. C'est presque
mathématiquement irréalisable. Si
quelqu'un en arrivait là, il montrerait
que le réseau de Bitcoin est possible à
corrompre et à ce moment-là le réseau
Bitcoin s'effondrerait. plus personne
n'aurait confiance en lui. Donc même le
plus gros des requins au monde voulant
s'emparer d'une puissance, d'une
gouvernance, d'une finance, personne n'a
d'intérêt à devenir le maître de ce jeu.
C'est donc pour ça que socialement, à
part pour un comportement purement
antisystème, d'où le fait que
techniquement et mécaniquement, ça ne
doit pas être possible. Le meilleur
moyen qu'on ne vole pas les 50 € sur la
table, c'est de ne pas les laisser.
Malgré tout, humainement et sur la pire
dérive au monde qui est l'ego humain et
le comportement individuel alors qu'on
devrait essayer de penser à quelque
chose qui s'élève au-delà au moins un
peu des intérêts particuliers. Bitcoin a
en plus d'une technologie merveilleuse
réussi à bquer cette problématique. Ce
n'était jamais vu dans du code. Ça n'a
jamais je crois à ma connaissance été
aussi pleinement posé dans du ma
question initiale c'était qui réglemente
qui surveille qui bac. Alors, on a
l'autorité de marché fin de la MF en
France, les autorit
dans la régulation. Oui.
Qui surveille ce qui se passe.
Ouf ! La CPR, la MF. Alors, on est dans
un marché qui est très jeune, il y a des
charlatans. D'ailleurs, c'est
l'environnement parfait. C'est compliqué
mais on vous demande pas de comprendre.
Euh, il y a des gens qui ont fait
beaucoup d'argent avec sans
connaissance. Oh oui, j'en connais parce
qu'on en connaît tous dans le monde de
la cryptomonnaie.
On balance IA, intelligence
artificielle, blockchain, crypto et on a
l'impression que c'est à la portée de
tous. C'est l'endroit parfait pour
mettre un piège à idiot ou un piège à
crédule. C'est parfait. Les gens vont
tomber dedans. Voilà pourquoi il y a
beaucoup de charlatans. On dit les
cryptoonnaaies c'est que des arnaques.
Non, il y a beaucoup d'arnaques parce
qu'il y a des gens peu scrupuleux mais
c'était également vrai sur le Minitel.
C'était également vrai sur internet.
C'est également vrai sur beaucoup de
choses. Dès qu'il y a une complexité et
qu'on sait qu'on peut faire fortune, on
vient tirer un filet pour les club
crédules. Mais en attendant,
aujourd'hui, il y a une régulation alors
plus ou moins stricte, dangereuse pour
certains de l'écosystème, dangereuse
parce qu'on veut essayer de réguler une
finance décentralisée avec des règles
d'une finance centralisée, mais il
commence à y avoir des flux. C'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs que l'on ne peut
plus dire du tout factuellement que le
Bitcoin est anonyme. C'est faux. Le
Bitcoin est pseudonyme, on est derrière
une adresse et maintenant quand on veut
en acheter ou en vendre en tout cas dans
la plupart des pays du monde, on se doit
de fournir un KYC, Know Your Customers
et prendre de l'information sur qui est
derrière cette adresse en cas évidemment
d'abus de cette personne,
genre track, track fin, track financier,
track fin et tout ça, ils se sont
positionnés et je peux le dire, notre
société just Mining a des normes contre
le blanchiment d'argent et la lutte
contre le financement du terrorisme qui
quand Je compare ça à une banque de
quartier ne sont même pas du même
niveau. C'est très complexe pour nous et
parce qu'on a été très régulé et très
cadré. D'ailleurs, on a le directeur de
l'AMF, si je ne dis pas de bêtises, qui
a pris la parole sur BFM il y a 48 ou 72
heures et qui a dit "L'Union européenne
doit réguler ?" Non. Cadrer ? Non.
"Aider ?" Non. Non. contraindre le monde
des cryptomonnaies parce qu'on en est
pas tout le temps sur une réflexion de
cadrage pour laisser cette technologie
se développer sainement. On en est sur
un postulat, on en est sur un Il y a pas
que de l'intérêt technologique, il y a
également du Christine Lagarde en mode
non non, on va remettre la façon dont la
monnaie est. La monnaie, il y a un il y
a un droit régalien, il y a un état
régalien, ça doit rester entre les mains
de quelques personnes. C'est l'une des
grandes idées qui veut être détruite par
les personnes qui développent ce
système. Ouais. Alors euh plusieurs
plusieurs remarques. Euh d'abord, je
pense qu'on apprécie tous enthousiasme.
Merci. Mais ne voyez pas du tout ça
comme de la virulence. Le but n'est pas
là. C'est juste que je
Non non non non non. Je je je comment
dirais-je ?
Belle défense ed belle défense.
Mais on me le dit souvent et puis c'est
pas le but du tout et que ça m'engage
profondément.
Non non non. Je je je suis malheureux de
voir que
toutes les catégories d'âge, de sexe, de
couleur et d'opinion qui m'entour ont
perdu ont perdu de de la capacité
d'enthousiasme. Donc je suis content
qu'il qu'il y en ait.
Et bien sûr qu'il faut que ça soit
contagieux. Bien sûr, ça c'est la
première chose. La deuxième c'est que
je redoute que derrière cet
enthousiasme,
il y ait
des actes de foi.
Ah ça ça il lève quelque chose
d'intéressant parce que il y a certains
dans la communauté crypto
c'est tu sais un petit peu comme le clip
des inconnus avec skipy. Norm
il y a beaucoup de skipy dans les dans
dans la communauté crypto. Des fric
skipy quand même hein. des actes de foi
qui l'on appelle des arguments
d'autorité.
H
h
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce qu'un argument
d'autorité ? C'est que
je suis ta mère. Euh oui, c'est c'est
qu'effectivement en utilisant
un référentiel historique,
technologique,
peu importe,
un angle de vue,
j'avais adoré ton
un un de tes interviewés qui est le
patron de l'école de guerre économique
et qui utilisait toujours ce terme,
monsieur Arbulo,
c'est ça ?
ce ce terme de grille de lecture et il
dit en fait
nous regardons tous nos vies, nos
existences, nos problèmes en fonction
d'une grille de lecture. Bien,
je te propose d'avoir
un angle et je pense que c'est un peu
l'objet de notre rencontre de ce soir.
C'est un angle qui va au-delà
de l'expertise sur une crypto qui
incontestablement a aujourd'hui coché un
très grand nombre de de cases d'ailleurs
pour lui donner la valeur
la réputation et enfin t tous les
qualificatifs qui qui la considèrent qui
la concernent. Bien.
OK.
Petit petit retour en arrière.
Quand le mur de Berlin, j'y étais le
lendemain du jour où le mur de Berlin
parce que je traitais avec l'Allemagne
de l'Est à l'époque.
Moi j'y étais pas.
Non non non, tu tu n'étais pas
pour ça. Tu traitais avec l'Allemagne de
l'Est. Je travaille je travaillais
beaucoup avec les pays communistes parce
que j'adorais être accueilli sur des
petits aérodromes par une tatra noire
avec une
engagé par la DGSE pour faire ça
Non non non non pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout non non non mais j'ai j'ai
adoré ce ce momentl et donc je me suis
retrouvé
et la chambre été garnie par le parti
communiste ou pas
attends attends non non ça ça a été un
gag parce que en arrivant justement
à la réception le type me donne des
jetons
des tokens.
Et alors il y en avait un les yeux les
yeux frisent en disant bon
this is strictly for you parce que
j'étais avec des ingénieurs et cetera et
heureusement que j'avais comme copain un
attaché commercial à l'ambassade de
Prague à l'époque et cetera et qui
m'avait tout de suite dit, il m'avait
dit alors ce jeton vous ne l'utilisez
pas pourquoi ? Il me dit "Ben parce que
vous allez faire rentrer une charmante
jeune femme mais qui va vous [__] des
micros de tous les côtés."
Les micros les micros sont déjà là en
Oui, ils sont déjà là. Enfin bref, et
qui va essayer de vous attirer dans ses
bras pour en savoir encore plus et
cetera et cetera. Donc c'était une
réalité que j'ai vécu
à la fin à la chute du mur de Berlin.
Euh
un un livre euh
puisque je sais qu'à la fin tu nous
demandes toujours des livres.
Alors attends pour la fin.
Bon d'accord. Mais
c'est un garçon qui s'appelle Francis
Fukuyama
et le le titre est est surprenant
puisque c'est la fin de l'histoire.
En fait, c'est de dire
c'est
la fin de ton histoire en fait.
Non, c'est la fin de l'histoire des
combats entre la gauche, la droite, les
communistes, les capitalistes. C'est
fini. C'est fini.
N'ayez plus n'ayez plus de
préoccupation,
c'est fini. Le néolibéralisme
anglo-saxon progressiste avec des petits
tirets à chaque fois, néolibéralisme
anglo-saxon progressiste
est devenu la doctrine du monde.
Tout le monde va être heureux. On va
être dans un dans une société de
bisnounours euh de démocratie, de
vraies concurrence et cetera et
ils ont pris le fameux jeton qu'il
fallait pas utiliser. C'est ça.
Alors eux, ils ont pris le le le jeton.
Absolument.
Certains dirai qu'ils ont choisi la
bonne pilule des deux.
Ouais.
En fait
ou le suppositoire
le suppositoire
en fait il faut que tu comprennes que
nous sommes aujourd'hui
les héritiers.
de cette situation.
C'est comme ça que la génération le
ressent en tout cas et avec beaucoup de
peur et d'incompréhension parce qu'il y
a eu aucune éducation qui a même pas la
visibilité qui est là.
C'est un dogme.
C'est ça. Mais en plus de ça, c'est
quelque chose de très rapide qui nous
tombe dessus. On est dans on est déjà on
est dans un pays développé, on en a de
la chance mais aucune éducation
financière. Mais heureusement quel âge ?
24 ans.
Heureusement, on a une éducation mais on
a aucune éducation financière. Et on
nous laisse une bombe à retardement.
Ouais.
Bien caché, bien emballé, un cadeau en
mode "C'est génial, à la fin il y aura
plus aucun problème." On a pris le bon
jeton.
Exactement.
Et soit on est fou, on le voit et on a
l'impression de se battre contre un
système où plus on le comprend, plus on
se dit "C'est déjà trop tard et puis
j'en parle même pas sur les autres
l'environnement, le c, le non, on nous
en a donné plein des cadeaux. Au plein
nous des cadeaux."
Soit on nous dit "OK, t'enfonce pas trop
dans quelque chose, tu vas finir par",
il faut s'éloigner de cet extrémisme à
chaque fois pour essayer de retoucher le
curseur. Donc ça donne envie de
comprendre, ça donne envie de trouver
des solutions d'entre deux, mais on est
à peine en train de comprendre la
gravité de ce qu'il y a qui quand on en
prend l'ampleur totale, on se rend
compte qu'on est dépassé de très loin.
Et je ne vous parle pas de ceux qui
quand je leur parle de ça, oh ben de
toute façon, moi je m'en fous. Euh je
préfère profiter des belles années.
Après moi le déluge. Après moi le
déluge. Après moi le déluge. Alors
pourquoi pourquoi je fais cette
référence ?
c'est que effectivement
aujourd'hui
les propagandistes
de cette de ce dogme
ont des arguments d'autorité, ont plein
d'arguments qui qui ne qui sont
simplement des actes de foi, hein, du
genre c'est la techno qui va recréer la
croissance bio
qui va nous sauver. qui va nous sauver.
C'est ça qui crée d'ailleurs des sur du
très long terme qui finit par créer des
cadeaux qui sont des bombes en réalité.
Voilà. Le seul problème
aujourd'hui c'est plus vrai.
Non mais le seul problème c'est qu'on a
une [__] de
Je suis désolé pour de boussole
qui n'est plus la bonne.
Or pour que les cryptos existent, pour
que tes communautés passent de x
milliards à 10 x ou 100 x et cetera
parce que plus la communauté sera large
et cetera, plus tu vas te rapprocher des
critères.
Je suis totalement d'accord de la
monnaie.
Le seul problème, c'est que si il y a et
malheureusement c'est ce que je redoute,
c'est que si il y a ce décrochage
humain,
la problématique n'est plus dans une
solution technologique.
La problématique
marque un point quand même hein. Non non
et je suis d'accord et d'ailleurs
certains voient ça comme la ter
donc
je suis ici pour faire acte de de
d'humilité par rapport à ce que j'avais
pu dire et je l'ai déjà dit et je le
répète convaincu que la blockchain va
rentrer dans nos vies.
C'est une preuve de hauteur
hein. Et est-ce que et est-ce que cette
blockchain va être une une monnaie
suffisamment J'ai adoré un de tes mots
parce que c'est un de mes une de mes
bousonnes à moi, c'est la notion de
résilience. Bon,
ça tombe bien parce que là, on a plein
de questions sur la résilience qui
arrivent. Continue.
D'accord. Alors, la résilience, c'est
quand on arrive au fond de la piscine,
quel est quel est le moyen de de
redécoller ? Comme je pars du principe
que malheureusement avant tes 30 ans,
tu nous je connaîtrai
un moment de fracture humaine, politique
sociale.
C'est un paroxisme inimaginable.
Ouais.
Absolument.
C'est un très dou.
Pourquoi ? Mais c'est simplement parce
qu'il va être proportionnel à une
situation très simple. c'est que nous
avons nous collectivement et et et les
pouvoirs politiques ont utilisé comme
unique moyen de sortir d'une crise
d'émettre de l'endettement massif.
Donc on se trouve dans une situation où
nous n'avons plus de munition.
Il faut il faut dire aussi pourquoi
l'endettement massif. Alors, mis à part
le côté infrastructure et le le côté
bullshit de certains politiques qui
disent que c'est normal la dette, on a
fait de la tête pour faire de la
suordnation de vote. Voter pour moi, ça
ira mieux demain. On a arrosé tout le
monde, les associations, tout tout le
monde a reçu du pognon.
Donc c'était normal de faire de la dette
parce que c'était comme ça qu'il fallait
se faire élire.
Ouais.
Ouais. Le problème c'est l'humain.
Mais justement,
c'est ça le maillon. Quel que soit le
modèle qu'on trouve aujourd'hui pour
redécoller en dessous de la piscine, on
va retomber au fond de la piscine.
Alors la métaphore du de rebond dans la
piscine, ça ressemble quand même à un
rebond du chamor hein. Le et rebond du
chat mort lesté avec un parpin de boomer
depuis les 50 dernières années et on
lance le champ.
Owen, il a la position du chamor, c'est
qu' il est censé refaire du moins sa
génération
ou du parpin. Moi, j'ai plus de
encore s connaiss bien le parpin.
Le le il est censé du moins sa
génération, notre génération, on est
censé
rattraper les tomb de parpin qui ont été
balancés sur les chamors et on est censé
relever nos manches. Sauf que qui
détient le l'argent, c'est ta
génération.
Ouais. qui n'a aucun intérêt à lâcher un
peu de pognon. C'est ta génération.
Qui va se battre bec et ongles pour pour
pas perdre ses privilèges. Ta
génération.
C'est ma génération.
Donc je pose une question. Quand les
jeunes se vengeront ?
Alors justement de
c'est presque on on pourrait presque ce
soir faire un appel l'appel de Sky le 11
novembre. Ah non non pas de politique.
Attends.
Ah ouais puis mauvaise date et tout, il
y a plein de trucs qui
c'est une bonne date mais ça peut être
interprété comme un politique. Non c'est
c'est une renaissance. Voilà ce soir
nous décidons d'une renaissance. Bon
dans cette renaissance je dirais qu'il
faudra mettre autant de techno que
d'humain.
Oui.
D'accord.
Je le pense.
Et je fais un clin d'œil à Stéphanie qui
est là. euh de l'autre côté de l'écran
sur le fait que elle m'a convaincu de
rentrer
dans dans ton espace parce que j'ai vu
des règles de gouvernance
qui fait référence à un mot qui est
sacré pour moi qui est le tir de
confiance
et
et on en a vu que dans le Bitcoin qui se
sont fait avoir.
Tout à fait.
Je je me suis battu toute ma vie et j'en
ai eu des récompenses.
C'est que quand on me fait confiance,
je considère que j'ai une responsabilité
suprême de faire ce pourquoi on m'a fait
confiance.
Oui.
Suprême
la congruence.
La congruence supérieure à toute autre
forme de contrainte. Et donc à partir du
moment où je souhaite être tiers de
confiance confiance, je dis
en imaginant que j'ai un un peu de
pouvoir dans les dans les mois, les
années où j'aurai encore la gnac que
j'ai ce soir. OK ? de dire comment je
fais l'articulation entre l'humain et la
techno en sachant que je vais avoir
à à affronter tout ce que tu viens de
dire Skype
sur le fait que c'est ma génération qui
va
tout bloquer en se disant de toute façon
je vais aller 50 milliards mais euh je
veux en garder au moins 40 ou je veux en
garder au moins 30 en sachant que ce
sont des milliards artificiels, hein.
Ce sont des milliards qui n'ont pas de
réalité. puisque en cas de vente
brutale, pas
j'ai traversé j'ai traversé des crises
où je peux le dire à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent ce soir sur certains titres ou
certaines valeurs ou certaines
obligations, la paumbe sera de 95 voir
99 %
et ça parle aux gens du monde des
cryptomonnaies d'ailleurs.
Absolument.
Et en moyenne, allez, on va se prendre
50 %. Bien, à partir de là, comme
l'outil
de sortie de crise, c'est celui qu'on a
utilisé pour nous mettre dans la crise,
c'est là où nous sommes devant une
problématique
qui est historique au vrai sens du
terme. Ah non non, il y a jamais eu il y
a jamais eu cette situation où
nous avons utilisé avant la crise, je
parle pas du Covid, avant la crise,
les remèdes à cette crise.
Et c'est c'est comme si on on voulait
soigner, on a rendu on a rendu
diabétique des populations et on ne peut
plus envisager que d'utiliser nos nos
stocks de sucre.
Donc mon point c'est que
et c'est toi qui l'a utilisé en en
disant il y a il y a la problématique de
l'humain, c'est que effectivement
si ce soir nous pouvions arriver à
convaincre ne serait-ce que 1 3 5 % de
tes auditeurs sur le fait qu'il y a une
réalité à la situation économique que
j'ai décrue, qu'il y a une réalité à ce
que tu est en train de construire
et que nous allons devoir parce que là
on parle d'une page blanche, on n jamais
vécu ça et c'est là où il faut être un
peu couillu, c'est de se dire "Je n'ai
aucun référentiel existant
ou overru
hein
ou au overru." Oui, dans la mesure où il
faut réellement qu'on parte d'une page
blanche
et il y aura un conflit au milieu parce
que le vas communicant ne conviendra pas
du tout au vas qui se fait vider quoi
qu'il arrive et même si on peut remettre
un peu plus de noblesse et d' on va dire
d'agnosticité dans ce nouveau vase,
mine de rien, on a des très très malins
du premier qui sont déjà dans le
deuxième en train de prendre de la
valeur
avec des filets. Alors même si
l'émission est quand même un peu
extensible, on a on a quand même
Non non mais voilà, je crois qu'on a Je
vais lire avant de balancer quelques
questions d'Internet, je vais lire un
commentaire pour Owen et je vais te
demander ce que tu en penses.
Quel petit faute d'orthographe
mais c'est pas grave. Owen, tu es validé
par l'AMF avec ta société just Mining.
Tu dis qu'on a besoin de des régulateurs
pour que le monde de la crypto
s'épanouisse. C'est à cause de mecs
comme toi qu'on va se retrouver avec des
cryptos centralisées, des passeports
sous blockchain au lieu de mettre aux
gens ou au lieu de permettre aux gens de
comprendre le Bitcoin, l'open source et
toute sa philosophie de trois points de
suspension. À l'image d'Internet
aujourd'hui, les finalités voulues par
les très early. Alors, je te laisserai
trly c'est ce départ
et les Cyberpunk
ne seront pas.
Alors, le problème c'est que il y a eu
des valeurs à la création de Bitcoin.
Les cyher punk à la base sont on c'est
ceux qui ont pensé à chiffrer ce qui
circulait sur internet pour ne pas que
un gouvernement ou une société puisse
écouter en abuser. On disait que c'était
une folie, on disait que c'était des
malades jusqu'à ce qu'on ait l'histoire
Snowden, par exemple. Donc il y a eu des
très très bonnes valeurs et d'ailleurs
ce sont eux qui font partie des gros
mouvements qui ont poussé le Bitcoin.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y
avait également de l'extrémisme dans ces
réflexions. Pas que c'était évidemment
pas que. J'aime pas dire une chose dans
le sens où quand on dézoome et qu'on
prend et qu'on modère son propos, on se
rend compte que ce n'était pas le que.
Et je pense que il y en avait qui était
extrémiste et heureusement qu'on a pas
appliqué que leur solution à eux. Tout
comme le Bitcoin peut-être une bonne
solution mais c'est un entre deux. Je
pense que le je pense que totalement
réguler avec les mécanismes de la
finance centralisée, c'est dangereux.
Totalement totalement décentralisé,
anonyme avec un contrôle pour le peuple,
c'est dangereux aussi. Ça doit être
modéré. Ça doit être un échange, ça doit
être un commun accord, ça doit être une
discussion qui même en cas de désaccord
est réouverte systématiquement. C'est
malheureusement ça. C'est chronophage la
vie. C'est un effort constant. Et
vouloir dire que ce sera tout d'un côté
ou tout de l'autre, ça marche que d'un
temps et ça peut être dangereux. Ce que
je veux dire, c'est que je suis pour le
côté discret de la vie. On peut avoir sa
marque de yaourt préférée, on peut avoir
sa catégorie pornographique préférée si
on veut. On est un être humain, on a le
droit d'avoir ses libertés personnelles,
sa pudeur, ses envies. On a le droit de
ça.
Par contre, malheureusement, c'est un
exemple que j'ai donné, le but c'était
d'aller d'être clivant sur ce sujet. Ce
que je veux dire, c'est que généralement
quand quelqu'un a vraiment besoin d'être
anonyme, quand quelqu'un ne veut
vraiment pas être tracé, quand quelqu'un
a un vrai besoin fondamental d'être
totalement caché, malheureusement, c'est
rarement pour la marque de pot de
yaourt. D'accord ? Et c'est ça qui est
triste. J'étais pour une liberté, moi
aussi. J'ai commencé avec cette énergie
et ce clivage du liberté, l'argent au
peuple, cette et quand on dézoome, j'ai
également vu parce qu'on a une société
des gens qui essayent de blanchir de
l'argent. On a également vu des gens qui
essayent de faire des choses horribles
et c'est là que je me rends compte qu'à
chaque fois que j'ai une idée en mode la
régulation et je l'ai vraiment eu. Le
régulateur veut nous tuer. C'est une
honte. C'est une ces méthodes sont trop
strictes. Il ne nous a pas compris. Il
nous met en danger. C'est vrai. Mais ne
rien faire du tout et accepter aucune
régulation mène à des dérives au moins
tout aussi tout aussi graves.
Je suis encore plus d'un côté des
libertés de cet échange que d'un côté de
régulation stricte. Mais en attendant,
je suis désolé de dire à ceux qui sont
très extrêmes d'un côté ou très extrêmes
de l'autre que je pense que leur leur
solution n'est pas bonne. Il y a
peut-être pas de nouvelles solutions.
Peut-être qu'il y a ne serait-ce que sur
l'antimony laering et le financement du
terrorisme. Je ne peux pas dire que
cette personne mais je ne peux pas non
plus tolérer que des gens blanchissent
de l'argent, financent du terrorisme et
qu'on ne puisse pas tracer ses flux. Je
suis désolé de le dire. La bonne réponse
est un entre deux. Et je suis désolé de
le dire, je n'ai pas de solution
concrète, stable à appliquer maintenant,
tout de suite. Il faut débattre, il faut
démarrer cette réflexion-là. Partir d'un
constat, d'une maladie, trouver un
médicament, expérimenter et faire ce que
l'homme a toujours fait, une
incrémentation empirique, bienveillante
et éclairée en essayant de en essayant
de nous en sortir. En fait,
Raphaël, tu veux rajouter un mot ? Oui,
en fait, un des mots dans cette
réflexion que nous avons avec des gens
des personnes hommes femmes de ce que
j'appelle ta communauté blockchain,
crypto, métaverse et cetera, c'est de
dire c'est de dire
comment peut-on être éthique ? Bon, ce
mot ce mot euh
qui est propre à chacun aussi. Alors,
attends, attends. Justement, pour moi,
quelqu'un qui dit qui revendique "Ah
mais moi, monsieur, je suis éthique, je
lui dis au revoir monsieur."
Dans la mesure où on ne peut pas
s'autoproclamer
éthique, c'est son comportement qui tend
vers une éthique. Étion d'un homme
absolument. Et euh on me demande de on
m'a demandé de d'écrire quel serait le
premier euh le premier critère. Et je
dire c'est très simple, c'est la clarté
et l'intelligibilité.
C'est-à-dire que ce que l'on dit à
un/ers
doit être totalement compris par ce
tiers. Déjà là, on part sur un socle
de compréhension mutuelle qui permet d'y
accéder.
ce que je voulais dire au-delà de cette
réflexion parce qu'en fait tu tournes
autour de l'éthique
dans dans ce que tu disait avant, c'est
que nous avons
euh nous avons devant nous et alors toi
encore plus que moi parce que moi ma vie
je je j'arrive au bout. OK. Bon, toi tu
la commences et c'est le défi de cette
génération.
Et en ce jour de 11 novembre où nous
fêtons des guerres contre l'abomin des
Oui, nous fêtons des victoires contre
contre l'abomination,
c'est de dire que le défi de ce qui
vient
doit être toujours mis sous l'angle de
l'humain qui est devenue et j'en suis le
témoin depuis 40 ans, la variable
d'ajustement du système.
Ce qui est horrible. C'est horrible. Ah
ben c'est alors là où c'est horrible et
c'est là où je dis mais soyez réalistes,
soyez raisonnables, mais ils ne sont pas
réalistes mes pères ne sont pas
réalistes.
Est-ce qu'ils sont pas psycho euh est-ce
qu'ils sont pas devenus qu' capsis ?
Est-ce queil y a pas des mégalot euh
complètement galvanisés au pouvoir, au
pognon ? Non mais ils sont ils sont tout
ils sont tout ça mais le seul problème
c'est que ils sont dans le déni dans la
mesure où ils n'ont plus le courage
la force de démarrer d'une page blanche
pour
parce que c'est c'est peut-être plus
possible quand je vois l'intrication
des des problèmes qu'on peut avoir les
ramifications, les racines
interconnectées
mélangées entre la production
énergétique la démographie Puis les
fonds de pension qui payent les
retraites des fonctionnaires,
des fonctionnaires qui ont été brassés à
coup de t'inquiète pas, tu auras le
boulot à vie, tout se passe bien, la
retraite, tout se passe, tout ira bien.
Est-ce que le pour me faire l'avocat du
diable de de de ta caste, est-ce qu'ils
sont tout simplement conscients que on
Je suis pas autorisé à être vulgaire, on
a simplement foiré la partie.
Mais non, mais attends, il faut il faut
se mettre dans cette situation et je
rends grâce à la vie que j'ai et que
j'ai vécu. J'ai vécu avec un SDF pendant
6 semaines. J'ai côtoyé des hommes qui
me faisaient monter dans leur jet. J'ai
vu des ingénieurs, j'ai vu des ouvrières
sur un plateau à à mettre un un pruneau
sur des sur des qu et et l'équipe de
télévision en face disant "Mais c'est
con ce que vous faites ?" Et les trois
ouvrières disant "Mais monsieur, je me
lève le matin,
pas de boul con. Non, je me lève le
matin et je sais que je vais retrouver
mes copines. Et heureusement, on a un
patron qui n'a pas quand même qui n'a
pas mis un robot parce que bien sûr, un
robot, il peut mettre le pruneau ou le
raisin de Corinthe. Mais moi, je suis
content, je suis avec mes camarades, je
parle à la cafétérière et cetera et
cetera. Bref,
donc
mon père a eu une bonne influence sur
toi.
Ah ben non, c'est évident. Merci, merci
de me le dire puisque j'ai une j'ai une
adoration pour mon père
et d'ailleurs, il faut pas que j'en
parle trop parce que sinon ma ma ma voix
va se casser. En fait, le le point c'est
ayant vu ces différents univers avec des
Mexicains, des Canadiens, des Juifs, euh
des des musulmans, des des maghrébains,
des incrédules, des agnostiques, des
athé, des j'ai tout ça. communauté et
d'un éclectisme rare. Bon, et cet
éclectisme me permet quoi ? Il me permet
de dire il y a des éléments intemporels
de l'homme. Il y a nos mesquinerie, il y
a nos dénis, il y a il y a il y a tout
ça. Mais il y a une grandeur de l'homme
et que le monde et que le monde dans
lequel je vis s'est coupé de ça.
Ils sont dans des dans des entres sois
du club de voile, du club de golf, du
club de chasse, du club et cetera,
des Marseillais contre les Alsaciens.
Ils font les rally ensemble,
il font ils font ils font des rall aussi
dans le monde de la blockchain mais bien
sûr. Mais le seul problème, mais tu en
as dans le monde ouvrier bien sûr. Ô
non mais attends, le seul problème c'est
que cet entre soi quand ils n'ont pas le
pouvoir
en fait ils le subissent.
Alors que eux
ce que nous évoquons ce soir ne leur
parvient pas.
Et c'est l'appel du 11 du 11 novembre
chez Sky, c'est de dire il faut que
chacun d'entre nous, enfin tous ceux qui
sont convaincus de ce que nous
échangeons,
hein, de SVW et que nous que nous
échangeons entre nous librement
justement euh dans cette pièce, nous
sommes de vrais démocrates. On échange
sur des idées qui sont pas tout à fait
les nôtres, mais on en échange
librement. Bon,
que ça leur parvienne parce que ils
n'ont pas la la fois précédente où tu
m'avait invité, tu disais "Mais est-ce
qu'ils n'entendent pas le bruit des
piqus ?" Bon, et j'avais
les fourches, les fourches
ou les fourches, j'avais pas totalement
percuté euh le le le 4 mars. Non, ils
l'entendent pas.
Ils l'entendent pas parce qu'ils ont un
casque bose avec une musique ou
classique ou machin et cetera ou autre
marque.
Ou autre marque bien sûr. Mais
bon, c'est pour les pauvres.
Le truc, je voudrais juste mettre une
phrase à ce moment-là.
J'ai vu des gens avec ses fourches, avec
ses piques qui ont eu l'occasion d'être
porté par une corde et maintenant ils
ont couru et ils ont été s'acheter un
casque et ils écoutent du jazz.
Ah mais attends
et je dois être franc, j'en ai fait
partie
sans même savoir ce que c'est et j'en
fais partie. Et ce que je veux dire
c'est que je vois la captation de valeur
qui peut y avoir dans le monde de la
cryptomonnaie. Même s'il y a un bon
moteur qu'il y a des bonnes valeurs,
comme tout va tellement vite comme on
est tellement jeune également. Enfin, je
parle pour moi, mais il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont plus de recul. Là, là,
Raphaël disait en fait la déconnexion
sociale.
Mais ça déconnecte aussi d'être dans ce
nouveau
Oui, mais justement, attends, ce que je
veux dire et c'est c'est c'est un de mes
messages de ce soir, c'est que
je remercie tous ceux qui nous regardent
et qui m'ont invité à rentrer dans leur
préoccupation.
Et on remercie à la communauté de nous
financer pour pouvoir permettre de la
création ce type d'espace. On a le temps
où il y a personne pour nous dire il y a
un slogan pub dans 2 minutes où tu peux
pas dire ça tu peux pas inventer si sans
notre communauté qui nous protège qui
nous ba qui tous les jours est là avec
nous et on voudrait les remercier au
passage. Ah mais attends, alors je je je
rends grâce hein euh une fois de plus
dans la mesure où
je vois des gens extrêmement ouverts
et qui acceptent quand je leur disne
vous enfermez pas dans un entretoit
justement de bitcoiners
alors qu'il soit décentralisé pas
centralisé on s'en fout de tout ça dans
la mesure où les challenges, les défis
auxquels nous allons tous être
confrontés vont devoir faire exploser
le carcan des entres soi.
C'est je sais pas si je suis clair dans
mon dans mon message. C'est-à-dire ne
regardons pas le monde sous l'angle des
fonds de pension ou sous l'angle des
cryptomonnaies ou sous l'angle de la
production agricole ou sur c'est on est
devant un défi qui est totalement
incompréhensible aujourd'hui de cette
grande régression.
Je pense que tu apportes un souffle de
d'enthousiasme et peut-être de solution.
Mais il y a il y a quelque chose de
limitant là-dedans. Comme ça va
tellement vite, tellement plus vite. Je
me souviens de certains postulats et
paroles fortes que je pouvais avoir il y
a un an par exemple. Et quand je fais le
delta entre qui je suis aujourd'hui, ce
que je pense et ce que j'ai dit il y a 1
an, je vois un gros relic normal, je
suis encore en train de me construire.
Surtout à ce moment-là, c'est
exponentiel, des gros changements
d'idées, des gros changements de
position. de par notre maigre
expérience, je peux vivre quelque chose
qui très vite me fait changer d'avis sur
certains points. Et donc, on va devoir,
et c'est ça qui est inquiétant comme
tout comme aujourd'hui, je suis en train
d'ancrer sur internet une prise de
position, certaines réflexions et je
vais peut-être évoluer et ça internet
n'oublie jamais. Mais la tr la chose qui
est encore derrière, c'est que on va
devoir faire plus que prendre des
paroles et de donner des paroles. On va
devoir prendre des décisions violentes,
strictes, tirer le frein à main, mettre
la main sur le volant.
On vient à peine de savoir passer une
vitesse.
Et alors tu as des zombies derrière toi,
faut faut apprendre à conduire, hein.
Mais mais on fait forcément des belles
erreurs.
Attendez, attendez, il y achement de
questions. Il y a il y a
énormément de questions et d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui posent des questions, je
tiens à vous dire qu'on refera des
émissions sur ce sujet-là, qu'on note
bien vos questions et que et qu'il y a
des questions super intéressantes. Je
vais essayer d'en poser à nos deux
invités.
Question pour vous deux. Imaginez-vous
une tempête solaire,
d'accord ? Tempête solaire, un trou, un
trou, hop, ça décharge fort. Le réseau
électrique prend sévère. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? La résilience, s'il y a plus
de réseau, il y a plus d'électricité,
ton Bitcoin, tu en fais quoi ?
Alors,
tu vas le chercher où ?
Déjà, il y a plus d'électricité. Très
très rapidement. L'humanité a d'autres
problèmes que le Bitcoin.
Très très rapidement. D'ailleurs,
rappelons que le Bitcoin et passez-moi
l'expression, c'est un paix dans une
tornade actuellement d'un point de vue
des volumes, hein. C'est très clairement
ça.
Donc, on parle du Bitcoin, mais il y
aurait d'autres très gros problèmes, les
banques, les États, tout le reste de
bien moins résilients que ça qui seraiit
dans la même situation parce qu'on ne
sait plus vivre aujourd'hui sans ça ou
du moins très très difficilement.
Première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est
que il y a quand même des fous et moi
j'aime les appeler des fous, mais c'est
très bienveillant pour le coup qui ont
fait un système
défé. des fellé
parce qu'il laisse passer la lumière.
J'adore les gens qui sont totalement
atypiques et qui ont une réflexion avec
de la bienveillance sur un fond de
bienveillance mais qui sont complètement
fous dans leur domaine ou complètement
fêé. Il y a déjà des gens qui ont fait
en sorte qu'avec l'électricité contenue
dans les batteries de nos téléphones, on
puisse mettre à jour la blockchain d'un
point de vue satellitaire.
Alors sauf si là tempête solaire
satellite aussi. Mais à ce moment
non mais non mais non attends après on
peut parler Corée du Nord si tu veux.
Corée du Nord
à ce moment-là, s'il y a un blackout
total de tout, oui, désolé, ce n'est pas
plus résilient que tout ce qu'on a
réussi à créer depuis la création de
juste avant.
L'or là, t'inquiète pas, il peut y avoir
une une éruption solaire. Euh l'or, ça
tient, tu es tranquille. Oui, oui, oui,
oui, mais pas la population, pas la vie,
nos échanges, le monde, ça part en ville
complet sans internet leur l'argent et
la poudre. Ça marche bien.
Alors,
oui, c'est The Walking Dead. C'est The
Walking Dead.
En fait, en fait euh je je je rebondis
sur ce que tu viens de dire dans la
mesure où ma communauté
commence à entrouvrir la porte sur le
risque climatique,
il serait temps.
Attends, attends. Mais et c'est très
amusant alors avec toutes les
hypocrisies, marketing et cetera. Mais
allez, là aussi il faut il faut il faut
comment dirais-je ? Il ne faut pas être
que cymique. C'est bien
il commence à y en avoir qui
réfléchissent vraiment. Tu
as pas envie de faire un gérond toi d'un
de ces quatre ?
Un quoi ?
Un gérond tocide.
Qu'est-ce qu'un gérondide ? Tu prends
tous les lieux de flinguer mais attends
attends attends.
Je dis ça je dis ça avec boutade.
Attends Sky Sky juste une chose
dans ma communauté ce sont pas les
hommes de mon âge qui sont à convaincre.
C'est les femmes.
Alors d'abord les femmes ou les
maîtresses trop d'un coup
parce que ell disent quoi mais mes
séchelles, mon machin mon truc et
cetera. Bon
mais en réalité c'est la c'est ta
génération qui est la plus hostile ce
sont attends c'est ta génération de ceux
qui votent pour monsieur Macron.
Mais ma génération vote pas Macron. Non,
si tu as des hommes de 40 ans, tu as 40
ans à peu près.
Un peu moins.
Un peu moins. Enfin, à un moment s'il
arrive à sa position, c'est qu'il y a
une mais c'est simplement parce que eux
sont dans l'espérance de continuer de
vivre selon les règles de monsieur
Fukuyama et et et de la grande
régression cachée. Ils sont très très
heureux, hein. Donc,
vous est en train de me dire que les
fous ont pris le contrôle de l'asile.
Oui. Ouais, c'est la la l'image est
belle.
Des vieux avec une démence avancée
ont pris le contrôle de l'asile. À ce
momentl comme une solution. Non non, je
je peux te dire Non, je peux te dire de
façon je peux dire à je peux dire à à
tous nos à tous nos auditeurs, c'est que
dans la génération des plus de 60 ans,
il y a beaucoup plus de réflexion sur
les risques à venir que dans la
génération des 40 ans que je côtoie.
Pas mal, pas faux. C'est la la
génération de nos grands-parents.
Alors, je parle pas de ce de 80 de 80
ans parce que eux sont absolument mais
c'est aussi la sagesse qui fait ça parce
qu'on a également du recul et qu'on l'a
vu encore parce que ils ils ont eu
encore des souvenirs de guerre de de
pauvreté et cetera. Donc mais c'est la
prise de recul. Quand on a faim, on
pense à maintenant, tout de suite,
aujourd'hui, on peut faire des choses
graves.
Attends, c'est c'est je je vous me
faites dévier de ma faites dévier
l'électron de de sa course.
Tu parlais de de la réaction
effectivement si jamais il y a une
tempête solaire et que c'est le
blackout. Ce que je veux dire par
l'ouverture
de la prise de conscience au risque
climatique, c'est que quelque part,
c'est une sorte d'alibi.
C'est-à-dire
ah oui oui, tu veux parler de ce risque.
Bon mais effectivement à échéance de 20
30 40 ans et cetera.
Et moi je leur dis mais attendez le
problème climatique
vous vous n'y penserez même pas parce
que si effectivement dans la rue c'est
les émeutes et que on vous crève vos
bagnoles, on on on fasse des des des
voitures tampon dans vos vitrines pour
pour piller, mais le risque climatique
sera le le dernier de vos soucis. Donc
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est que
parfaitement conscience. Regarde, il y a
des compounds, il y a des compounds pour
riches un peu partout. Ça se développe
en France avec caméras, sécurité privée,
chiens, les gens ils vent se bal comme
comme aux États-Unis. il le sentir. Les
les milliardaires se font des des î de
sécurité en Nouvelle-Zélande et dans des
territoire comme l'Argentine. Donc il le
sent venir. Le réchauffement climatique,
les les émeutes sociales que tu nous
parles de du dont tu nous parles, ils le
sentent. On est en train de faire une
prospective sur comment les riches sont
en train de se planquer en ce moment.
Mais rien que le Covid le rien que le
Covid a suffi pour ça quand on voit des
gens pour du papier toilette. Ouais.
Ouais. Non mais il y a eu les gilets
jaunes quand quand les gilets jaunes ont
débarqué sous l'arr de triomphe.
Paraîil ouais. Non mais paraît-il
paraît-il que en plus haut lieu, ils ont
reçu des consignes en disant "Tu lâches
tout parce que sinon ils vont nous
égorger, tu leur files ce qu'ils veulent
parce que sinon ils vont débarquer chez
nous, ça va être séquestration et ils
vont nous expliquer la vie."
Quand quand l'autre porte-parole du
gouvernement s'est fait braquer son
ministère à coup de fenwick, il nous a
fait de l'huile. Il il a pincé le cuir
de de de de sa chaise avec l'arrêt des
fesses.
Donc il le sent bien venir. Ils sont pas
totalement cons.
Oui mais
et le réchauffement climatique,
t'inquiète pas, il il sentent bien
venir.
Alors ça ça il sentent bien venir. Ce
que ce que je veux dire, c'est que
et probablement que beaucoup des gens
qui nous écoutent ce soir ne sont pas
réellement conscient sans tomber dans la
panique et cetera, hein. Bien sûr,
du fait que le risque financier et
économique est beaucoup plus imminent
que le risque climatique. C'est ça. Je
Et là, tu es en train de me dire que le
le le risque économique, c'est à 2 ans.
Là,
le risque économique, il est à 2 ans.
J'ai j'ai dit avant que W les 30 ans.
Donc
pour être franc, je suis vraiment
dépassé par ça. Je suis incapable de
quantifier et de percevoir le 2 4 6 8
ans. Ça c'est vraiment quelque chose où
il y a pas le recul nécessaire et malgré
ce que j'essaie de au rythme où nous au
rythme où nous sommes et étant donné que
la paix de Boussol dont je parlais tout
à l'heure
c'est que nous sommes aujourd'hui sur
une tendance et je ne vois aucun élément
de de la réversibilité de cette tendance
c'est qu'il faut entre deux 3 ou 4
dollars pour créer un dollar de
richesse. Bon, étant donné que la
boussole, c'est la production de ces
richesses, que tous les plans de santé,
la carte sanitaire, les plans
d'éducation, les infrastructures,
les adductions d'eau, toutes est
fonction de ce paramètre.
À partir du moment où on est dans ce
dans dans dans cette spirale de dingue,
le danger c'est que mes contradicteurs
me disent "Mais Raphaël, ton truc
n'existe pas puisqu'on n'en parle pas."
C'est l'argument parfait. Dans les dans
les dans les business school, on
n'étudie pas donc ça n'existe pas. dans
les grands journaux qui continuent quand
même de draîner une bonne partie de
l'opinion de la classe
et de l'argent public
et de l'argent public. D'accord. En
fait, on n'en parle pas. On ne parle pas
de ce risque parce qu'on ne veut pas le
voir, parce qu'on n' pas les solutions.
Mais il n'y en a pas de solution. La
seule solution, c'est le courage de se
dire avec des garçons comme toi qui ont
un éclairage que je n'ai pas et ta
génération avec des gens qui ont mon
éclairage de dire on se met à
travailler.
C'est ça qu' combler le fossé
intergénérationnel. J'en profite pour
reprendre la parole et poser une
question à Owen. Question d'Ibrahim
Owen. Question qui quoi permet de miner
et exécuter les transactions mondiales
que tout le monde plébiscite avec le
Bitcoin, l'altcoin Nvidia/AMD
donc USA. Aujourd'hui avec la pression
TAA, impossible de miner de main. Si ces
acteurs décident de brider ou de
contrôler, comme c'est déjà le cas sur
le LHR, comment faites-vous vos
transactions qui détient cette monnaie ?
Est-ce que la question a du sens ?
Pourquoi tu touches ?
Oui, pour j'ai un truc qui me gêne d'un
coup.
Tuas tu as un verre d'eau.
J'ai toujours de l'eau.
Ça fait pas de sens. C'est-à-dire que ça
cible, c'est une question de quelqu'un
qui connaît très très bien l'écosystème,
qui pose une question très technique,
très ciblée sur un problème. Il y a pas
d'enjeu sur ça. Surtout qu'il a cité
quatre cryptomonnaies. Moi, je vais
défendre celui qui pose la question qui
n'ont pas le même consensus, qui n'ont
pas la même méthodologie. Ce que j'ai
envie de lui dire, c'est que Bitcoin est
très très bien baqué par le proof of
work. Alors, les ordinateurs qui
travaillent, qui sécurisent, qui
fournissent la preuve de leur travail
pour garantir le réseau,
mais les cryptomonnaies d'usage sur
lesquels on va construire beaucoup
d'usage décentralisés, bien que ça ne
remet pas selon moi en cause le Bitcoin
et sa position qui est pour moi leur
numérique très clairement aujourd'hui
et bien ne seront pas basés sur du proof
of work.
Alors, il y a proof of et non mais il y
a aucun souci. Tu as le proof of work et
tu en as un autre, c'est le proof of
steak.
Exactement. Écologiquement parlant, ça
change quelque chose ?
Une division entre 1000 à 10000 de la
consommation énergétique qui n'est déjà
pas une aberration sur Bitcoin.
Ça
ce n'est pas une aberration écologique.
Un copain qui chauffe avec son mineur
quand même hein.
Ben justement, c'est quelqu'un qui en
plus de ça a trouvé l'une des trois
grandes réponses qui est la
récupération.
C'est quoi le problème ? C'est quoi la
différence entre un mineur de
cryptomonnaie et un chauffage électrique
? le chauffage, on fait chauffer une
résistance.
Le mineur, c'est la même chose, mais en
plus on sécurise des transactions et on
pérénise un réseau.
Et donc là, j'arrive à mon autre
question. Qu'est-ce qui se passe en cas
de pénurie énergétique ou du prix de
l'énergie qui explose ? Ça va faire
monter les Bitcoin, ça va pas les faire
monter, on pourra plus miner. Comment ça
va se passer
sur l'électricité ? Alors, on est tout,
on est sur des très gros cas
systémiques. C'est ça qui est dur.
J'aimerais pouvoir répondre mais depuis
que je suis né, il y a de l'électricité.
[__] je Voilà. Et c'est vrai qu'on me
demande de répondre à des éléments.
Combien de temps c'est combien de temps
ta plus grosse coupure d'électricité
dans ta vie de 24 ans ?
On a été en Corse quand même. Quand le
vent il souffle bien, des fois pendant
de 2 de jours, ça peut être un peu
particulier. Pour nous, c'est la folie.
C'est c'était impossible de
Mais pour mes parents
Raphaël, tu veux dire quelque chose ? Ah
ben je veux dire que effectivement le
euh c cette question est au cœur de mon
de mon souci,
de mon activité de lanceur d'alerte,
c'est de dire euh
comment comment sécuriseon
je vous rappelle que s'il n'y avait pas
eu un acharnement depuis 40 ans, nous
nous serions un/4 plus pauvre.
D'accord. Alors en fait en fait ce ce
quart de richesse qu'on a créé a été
créé artificiellement puisqu'on s'est
endetté 10 fois plus. Donc en fait on a
créé un passif nous permettant de créer
des flux.
Ouais mais c'est une c'est c'est un
affichage.
Mais c'est un affich impression. Enfin
non en comptabilité c'estd que j'ai j'ai
aggravé mon passif
de manière à sau à sauver à sauver mon
compte d'exploitation. D'accord. Bien et
la planète fonctionne sur sur ce
critère-là. À partir du moment où le
risque est humain,
ce qui me soucie, c'est que quand il y a
décrochage humain, les coupures d'eau,
les coupures d'électricité, les coupures
de de ce qu'on appelle les commodities,
hein, les commodités
peuvent devenir ce que j'ai vécu au
Mexique, ce que j'ai vécu dans dans des
périodes un peu dures en en mai 68,
c'est que effectivement à ce ce
moment-là, il n'y a plus il n'y a plus
euh il n'y a plus de pompe. On on va à
la pompe, la pompe est fermée, les cuves
sont fermées. Donc c'est comment
aujourd'hui
aborder
le défi
en n'étant pas trop dépendant d'une
technologie qui est elle-même dépendante
? Tu sais, il y a il y a un grand truc.
Je je devance une de tes questions
favorites, c'est
est-ce que tu es un ami imaginaire ?
Pour pour les pour les comment s'appelle
pour les jeunes, en fait, il y a une
espèce d'obsession sur le mot de liberté
et il y a une page
euh merveilleuse que je que j'ai
intégralement copié dans
fait pas du Macron, hein, pas de liberté
sans devoir ou une corée comme ça ou non
? Non non non non. De de Dostoyevski.
et qui dit simplement
que en fait quand on parle de liberté,
on parle de autonomie.
Ah bah oui, l'anarchie encore.
Oui, mais attends justement
à la vraie, je suis
le truc du du raconte. Je suis un vrai
autonome.
Tu me mets avec un coupe ongle, un peu
de ficelle et du papier journal. Je vais
m'en sortir beaucoup mieux que la
majorité des gens parce que je suis
autonome.
Toi, tu me donnes une baguette racis,
deux carré de sucre, je te fais avouer
n'importe quoi.
D'accord.
Non, mais tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Donc ne ne chérissons pas une liberté
qui est en fait une servitude en matière
au travers de cette grille de lecture
qui est la recherche d'autonomie.
Regardons tout quand on cherche de
l'autonomie, je me fais encore l'avocat
du diable. Quand on recherche de
l'autonomie, on accuse les gens d'être
sédicieux.
Ah bah bien sûr. Ah bah bien sûr.
Alors Elion Musk et et ses copains ultra
millionnaires cherchent de l'autonomie à
faire des paradis fiscaux en dehors euh
des frontières. C'estàd se mettre dans
les eaux internationales pour faire leur
deal. C'est de l'autonomie ça.
Alors,
je me fais l'avocat du Non,
non mais attends attends, tu tu as
complètement raison. Mais je veux dire
il y a très longtemps déjà que euh des
gens
que j'ai entreaperçu dans ma vie, hein,
acheter des des plateformes pétrolières
en zone internationale pour en faire des
microétats.
Tu tu peux faire un microétat d'une
plateforme pétrolière qui rouille
quelque part. Bon,
je je pour moi l'autonomie, je je
considère qu'un type comme Elon Musk,
enfin je le connais pas donc j'en sais
rien ou du du genre
mais du genre en fait il n'est pas
autonome. Il n'est pas autonome dans la
mesure où pour moi la la véritable
autonomie, c'est que quand tous les
moyens matériels qui sont mis à sa
disposition vient viennent à manquer lui
en tant qu'individu
lui en tant qu'individu, comment se
débrouillirait-il
conditionnel dans un univers où il n'a
plus tous les moyens qui lui sont
proposés ? Pour être fran, lui, je
m'inquiète quand même pas trop quand
même parce que vu l'esprit cartésien de
câbles, on est sur un truc, on est quand
même sur un sacré Mcgiver quoi. Il a
quand même dit à la NASA, je vais faire
ratterrir une fusée. Elle lui a dit non,
il a fait atterrir une fusée simple. Il
a quand même dit, on peut pas déplacer
ça à ça pour moins de 50 millions. Il a
mis des rondins de bois, il a mis une
fusée dessus, il l'ont fait rouler. Donc
sur le côté cartésien et je peux me
débrouiller quand même, Elon Musk c'est
quand même pas le pire. le truc qui est
vrai et puis pareil, il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui visent une extrême extrême
extrême richesse sans réel but derrière.
On est toujours à viser plus haut comme
ça, on sera to fail individuellement. Ça
ça bouffe un système.
Après je pas non plus me mettre l'avocat
enfin en étant l'avocat du diable quand
je vois ce qui se passe dans les
cryptonnaies, la valeur qui est capté,
toutes ces choses-là,
je vois quand même les mêmes mécanismes.
J'en joue moi-même. Donc je suis en
train d'apprendre les règles d'un jeu en
en est en train d'apprendre une morale.
Donc c'est très dur. Mais quand on
dézoome un petit peu Elon Musk et on
peut lui dire plein de choses de mal,
plein de choses de bien comme toute très
grosse personnalité de ce monde, il a un
objectif, il essaie de viser quelque
chose et peut-être que lui, on lui a dit
aussi quand il était jeune, ben le monde
va mal, le monde va brûler, démerde-toi.
Et lui, bah je sais faire, je sais faire
de la technologie, je vais trouver une
solution.
Question d'internet de Yannick,
une monnaie programmable
peut-elle signer la fin de la fiscalité
? les impôts à lever pourra être créés
par un protocole tout simplement.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Ah oui, mais mais je dirais que c'est
une une des angoisses que j'ai par
contre.
Pourquoi une angoisse ? c'est que dans
cette que vous avez tous compris cette
comment dirais-je cette recherche
d'autonomie d'une manière générale,
oui, je veux être libre avec les moyens
que j'ai de faire à peu près ce que je
veux dans le cadre des règles d'une
bonne d'une bonne vie
sociale et cetera.
Je suis extrêmement inquiet
de tendances qui sont soit dans des pays
du nord de l'Europe dont l'archétype est
la Chine qui prétend créer une
cryptoonnaie qui n'est pas une
cryptomonnaie au sens d'une gouvernance
décentralisée. Pas du tout.
On parle de la Chine quand même.
Non mais attends, non mais attends, mais
ils utilisent le mot,
ils sont pas fous, ils sont chinois.
Mais oui. Non mais attends, ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que comme le
disent à juste titre mes ancêtres de
Wall Street, la perception est la
réalité. Si effectivement les gens qui
nous écoutent aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
savent que Owen représente euh je dirais
une une une un/ tiers de confiance dans
l'univers de la crypto, c'est que si on
utilise le même mot de crypto alors que
c'est au service d'un parti unique qui
pratique la peine de mort
plusieurs fois par jour.
Ce n'est plus une cryptomonnaie. Donc à
partir du moment, et c'est la question
d'Ibrahim, c'est ça euh Ibrahim.
Oui. C'est de dire
non, c'est la question d'anicelle-là sur
la fiscalité.
Ah d'accord. C'est c'est de dire
effectivement
on peut régler plein de choses par la
par la technologie. Par contre, ayant
accompagné
un des un des grands de la techno euh et
et du big data dans son aventure
industrielle,
c'est de dire
le code c'est la loi, mais qui donne
l'instruction de rédiger le code ?
Très bonne question.
D'accord.
Donc en réalité, tant que ce n'est pas
une machine qui serait censée être
totalement harmonieuse et cetera, c'est
un être humain.
Ce sont des êtres humains qui touchent
le curseur de Bitcoin. et avec et avec
un un un énorme problème quand on dit
que la la loi c'est le code, c'est que
moi si je dis à mes informaticiens
faites ceci,
ai-je les moyens
de contrôler
les portes des robes
parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé, je
veux dire dans l'un des films sur la
crise de de 20082009 quand effectivement
le patron de la banque
Ouais. dit à 2h du matin, bon mais en
anglais ça veut dire quoi ? c'est que
lui-même alors qu'il est le président de
la banque n'est plus en mesure.
Ça s'appelle le principe de Peter.
Oui. Mais
quel est le principe de Peter ?
Bah le principe de Peter, c'est qu'on on
on Ah la la courbe de
c'est qu'on met alors pour résumer
trivialement, on met toujours le plus
demeuré à la à la fonction plus haute
parce que c'est là où il fait le moins
de mal.
Absolument.
En général, c'est le président directeur
général.
Oui, mais ce que ce que je veux dire par
là, ce qui ce qui est très j'avais été
au pot de départ d'un ancien patron de
il y a il y a 30 de la générale et qui
dit en fait je suis très content de
prendre ma retraite polytechnicien,
inspecteur des finances et cetera parce
que je ne comprends plus. C'était il y a
35 ans. Ben, je suis absolument certain
que aujourd'hui
des gens qui ne comprennent plus mais
qui restent en place.
Ah bah bien sûr, mais ça c'est le jeu
politique et cetera. Mais ce que je veux
dire par là, c'est que l'une des grandes
justement il n'est plus autonome
et donc il n'a plus matière à contrôler.
Donc la question sur la fiscalité, moi
je veux bien mais quelle est
l'exploitation dans ma vie perso que
l'information
à vertu
fiscale
va être
contre moi ? C'est pas c'est pas pour me
contraindre à être un bon citoyen sur le
plan fiscal. Ça à la limite puis en plus
moi je suis dans une situation plus que
simple he je veux dire un compte par
pas de celle des cryptomonnaies ou
non non mais je veux dire j'ai un compte
en banque depuis depuis 45 ans point
barre
et en France
diversifier finan et en France et cetera
non non et les actifs sont sont
immobiliés et cetera donc ce que je veux
dire c'est faisons très attention à ce
que
sous prétexte d'utiliser de la techno
pour venir donner des vertus ou des
outils de vertus,
elles ne deviennent des outils de
coercition.
Je suis totalement d'accord avec ça.
Sauf que on est à peine en train de
comprendre le problème du cadeau. La
technologie, c'est un bouclier. À la
base, il a pas été brandi comme une épée
pour tuer qui que ce soit. À la base, la
blockchain a été brandie comme un
bouclier. Donc, on en est à peine à
utiliser le bouclier pour la première
fois. Essayer de se protéger de quelque
chose que l'on ne comprend pas
proprement. Et on nous dit attention à
ce que votre bouclier soit pas une épée.
Les gens qui ont construit ça à
l'origine, enfin il y a différentes
pensées. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est
qu'on en est même pas à ce niveau-là de
réflexion. On en est à un, on sait qu'il
y a une bombe, ça va péter. On se met
derrière quelque chose en mode on veut
se laisser une porte de sortie, on veut
se protéger et on nous est on on est
déjà en train de nous dire "Ah, tu mets
pas derrière une porte. Si elle pète, tu
vas avoir des petits éclats de bois.
Attends, attends, il y a une bombe."
C'est ça. Absolument. Rowen,
il y a il y a une question que je ne
t'ai pas posée,
c'est que
il y a dans mon métier
quelque chose de
de comment dirais-je
de de très défini et de très réglementé
qui est le principe d'initier. OK ? Et
dans ce principe d'initier, il y en a
un. Moi, je suis initié en permanence,
mais ça ne veut pas dire que je connais
un délit d'initié.
Et ce que je me rends compte, c'est que
c'est un kitus moral le délit d'initié
parce que sur le papier dans la
cryptomonnaie, il y a pas de règle
sinon.
D'accord. Par contre,
quid du délit d'action de concert.
Je je
je veux bien un peu de développement.
Le développement c'est la chose
suivante. Je veux mettre la main sur une
entreprise.
Oui.
Si je dépasse
si si les seuils sont par exemple où je
dois me déclarer aux autorités de cont,
on peut faire une opéa hostile de
blockchain.
D'accord.
C'est je vais être toujours à 4,99 pour
ne pas être à 5 %. Et par contre, je
vais faire appel à des conseillers pour
me trouver toute une série de personnes
qui peuvent avoir le même intérêt. Donc,
vis-à-vis des autorités, il n'y a pas
d'action de concert mais en réalité il y
a une action de concert. C'est un délit.
Alors oui, mais non. Oui. Non, non,
c'est un délit. Attention, attends,
attends. Quand je dis c'est un délit, je
dis pas oui mais non, c'est un délit.
Donc dans la blockchain,
ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y a
même pire que ça dans la blockchain, il
y a certains tokens, on peut déléguer la
gouvernance mais pas leurs valeur.
Il y a certaines cryptomonnaaies, on
peut donner le droit de vote qui va avec
mais pas sa valeur. Donc c'est encore
plus facile pour ce genre de chos comme
pour les fonds sous gestion. On peut
déléguer le droit de les travailler mais
sans en déléguer la valeur. La personne
ne peut pas sauver avec la caisse. Des
mécanismes très intelligents d'ailleurs
sur plein d'aspects, mais c'est encore
un autre sujet. Ce que je veux dire
là-dedans, c'est que pareil, on n pas
d'obligation de déclaration. On en est
même pas là. Le délit d'initié n'est pas
proprement cadré dans tous les pays,
dans les cryptonnaies. Vraiment, on en
est même pas encore là. Pour ça qu'on
est déjà en train d'imposer une certaine
structure. On demande une certaine tenue
à un embryon. C'est ça qui est
compliqué, qu'il faut ramener quand même
de temps en temps sur la table. Mais les
quitus moraux sont censés rester les
mêmes
sur la forme et leurs abus.
Et puis également l'honorabilité du
dirigeant, la tenue de parce que il y a
du coup cet entre deux de régulation qui
est en train d'essayer de donner une
forme à tout ça.
Mais il y a plein de choses qui sont
quand même prévues par les protocoles.
C'est le concept même du proof of stake,
la preuve d'enjeu.
Théoriquement si 51 % des associations
sont immobilisées, pardon, si 51 % des
actions sont immobilisées, immobilisé
dans le protocole, personne n'est
actionnaire majoritaire. C'est presque
ça la preuve d'en jeu. Prouver qu'il y a
pas d'actionnaire majoritaire. Bloquer
la liquidité et prouver qu'il n'y a pas
de personne qui peut
D'accord. Mais donc en fait il peut y
avoir une action de concert.
Ouais. Et sur les plus petites
blockchain d'ailleurs, c'est ça qui fait
également la force du Bitcoin. C'est une
très grosse machine
sur les plus petits projets. C'est ça.
Je vous donne un exemple. Il y a plein
de cryptonnaies basées sur le même
protocole que Bitcoin. Si c'est dur
d'avoir 51 % de Bitcoin, quelqu'un qui a
2 % sur Bitcoin, il peut avoir 51 sur un
petit projet qui utilise le même
protocole. C'est ce que l'on appelle une
attaque 51. Évidemment, on n' pas
attendu l'être humain tout rapidement
les premiers, les plus malins, les
esprits capables de conceptualiser
pardon
les esprits capables tous deux vaccinés.
Les esprits capables de conceptualiser
ces notions mathématiques s'en sont
emparés. Il y a déjà des attaques, il y
a même des trucs bien plus
mathématiquement alors je vais dire
intelligents d'un point de vue
réflexion, pas du tout d'un point de vue
humainement. Les valeurs qui sont
parfois qui manque d'ailleurs même dans
la décentralisation. Il y a des gens qui
ne respectent aucun de ces quitus là et
au contraire à la guerre comme à la
guerre maintenant qu'on est livré à
nous-même battons-nous et c'est ce
derrière moi viendra le déluge. Ça
existe aussi dans ce monde-là. C'est
pour ça que c'est toujours un entre
deux.
Mais voilà par contre ça commence à être
encadré
les amis. les amis.
Ouais,
on arrive tard là. On va refaire des
émissions sur les Bitcoin, sur le
l'écosystème Bitcoin et on continuera à
mixer des personnalités différentes
autour de ces sujets-là parce que c'est
nécessaire. On voit qu'il y a énormément
à échanger entre vous deux et ça fait
vraiment plaisir. D'ailleurs, je vous
remercie. Je vous remercie tous les
deux.
Là, on arrive on arrive à la fin de
l'émission. On voudrait trois bouquins
chacun. Donc Owen, trois bouquins et
Raphaël trois bouquins
en moins d'une minute.
Et attends attends attends attends. Et
ensuite après chacun votre liste de
lecture, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations qui restera comme une
bouteille à la mer sur notre chaîne et
sur internet. OK.
Alors un bouquin vraiment factfulness
sur la factualité sur j'en ai j'en ai
appris beaucoup de choses et je suis pas
l'édition. l'auteur l'édition
euh Factfulness, je sais pas l'édition
mais c'est Hans Rosling. Et ensuite le
reste c'est sur mon éducation
personnelle. C'est pas un conseil que je
pourrais donner, ce n'est pas sur le
monde, la vie, le recul. Ça, moi j'aime
beaucoup Malcolm Gladwell notamment
Outlier et je lis beaucoup de cet
auteurl mais je ne lis pas grand-chose
parce que je me nourris d'autres types
de sources d'information, de contenu, de
podcast et de fait pour vous informer
d'ailleurs à
moi tout ce qui passe c'est un c'est un
un vrai une vraie bonne diversification
des sources que j'utilise. Je me je me
renseigne énormément de personnes qui ne
partagent pas du tout mon avis parce que
ça me permet de refaire mes idées. Mais
sinon euh internet est heureusement pas
doté que de bonnes informations, mais il
est tellement large et ouvert à tous, ça
permet de bien se fournir, je pense.
Tu as donné tes trois bouquins. Euh
Raphaël, juste avant euh euh comment tu
fais pour t'informer ?
Ah ben moi, j'ai des j'ai je dois dire
j'ai du push euh qui qui rentre, j'ai
quelques abonnements de papier le
weekend et cetera. Euh
vous avez un avis sur l'euro numérique ?
Oui, ça va. va exactement dépendre de
comment est-ce qu'il va être constitué.
C'est-à-dire que le la CBDC de l'Union
européenne, on ne peut absolument pas
dire si ce sera une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée. On a des idées. C'est
comme la Chine, elle va aller faire sa
cryptomonnaie. On avait des idées avant
qu'elle sorte. On a des idées. Ça semble
être un beaucoup de gens pensent que ça
va être un moyen de contrôler encore
plus la liquidité, de maîtriser encore
plus. En un simple bouton, on peut
prélever la TVA ou l'impôt sur un flux.
C'est très simple. En attendant, je ne
veux pas l'évasion fiscale. C'est bien,
c'est bien pour l'évasion fiscale.
Ah mais alors là pour Mais alors on en
aura là, c'est c'est plus que ça. C'est
un contrôle qui va au-delà de ça. Là je
on ne peut pas savoir mais encore une
fois je ne veux pas dire en amont que ça
va être malveillant, que ça va être
abusif parce qu'il ne faut pas non plus
être pessimiste, même si soyons franc.
C'est c'est comme dire on va le
gouvernement va monter un site internet,
il sera bon ou mauvais. Tout ce que je
sais c'est qu'ils vont faire un site.
C'est ça une cryptomonnaie. Et donc
aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas répondre, on
ne peut que spéculer et donc être trop
pessimiste ou trop optimiste. En
attendant, on peut dire aux gens :
"Renseignez-vous sur ce qui est une
monnaie équilibrée, décentralisée.
Apprenez, éduquez-vous, n'attendez pas
que ça vienne à vous et on sera capable
de juger cette monnaie quand elle sera
devant nous."
Raphaël, l'euro numérique, un mot pour
pour moi, c'est un
c'est
comment dire ?
Ça n'est encore qu'une idée dans la
mesure où
il faudra que le les gouverneurs de la
BCE se mettent d'accord
et avant que l'on ait l'accord de l'ex
Bundesbank
ou ou de la banque de France,
il y aura de l'eau qui aura coulé tous
les
aura de l'eau.
L'Allemagne joue un peu moins que les
autres avec ça. Non,
attends attends attends attends, on
refera des émissions. Raphaë, donne-moi
trois bouquins.
Alors, il y en a un parce que je me
souvenais que tu allais me poser, je
savais plus que c'était. Il y en a un
qu'il faut absolument que tout le monde
lise parce que ça se lit en une heure.
Euh c'est euh je sais plus quel est le
titre, si c'est le discours sur la
servitude volontaire
de la Boie.
De de la Boie,
un très très bon livre. C'est je veux
dire que ce que ce cet adolescent de 18
ou 19 ans au milieu du 16e siècle et
anticiper que nous étions dans des
situations de servitude volontaire à
l'égard du prince. Waouh !
Stratégie du larbin maintenant.
Ouais. Le le deuxième c'est que je
faisais référence à Fukuyama sur la fin
de l'histoire. Je je le réutilise dans
mes dans mes bouquins parce que pour
comprendre le dogme dans lequel nous
sommes, il faut partir de son crédau.
C'est que en fait c'est ce qu'il y a de
plus vertueux au monde donc ça va
s'imposer hein. Et c'est très dangereux.
Enfin je veux dire les moines la sainte
inquisition elle partait de là. Je veux
dire elle partait de
un bon sentiment.
Non non c'était un bon sentiment. Et
alors, il y en a un troisième que j'ai
découvert avec énormément de joie qui
s'appelle le bug humain. Je n'ai je me
souviens pas, c'est un type qui est un
spécialiste des neuro des neurosciences.
C'est prodigieux dans la mesure où il
dit en fait
la fois trop où on me le recommande.
C'est la fois trop où on me le
recommande à la maison parce que en fait
le il y a il y a dans notre carcasse là
il y a un débat violent entre ce qu'il
appelle le stratiumur
voilà entre le stratium qui est au cœur
au cœur du cerveau et qui lui ne gère
que nos pulsions. On a envie de bouffer,
de pisser, de baiser, de dominer l'eau,
et cetera et cetera. amour de faire
l'amour.
D'accord. Euh non mais parce que je je
je m'adapte à un jeune public. On est
très traditionnel ici hein.
D'accord. Et il y a le cortex qui lui
est le siège de la raison, de la
conceptualisation et cetera. Et donc il
y a un conflit entre le il y a un
conflit entre les deux. Euh et c'est
passionnant à à utiliser.
Rappelle-moi le nom de ton bouquin.
Le mien ?
Ouais.
Ah c'est le l'opportunité du Covid
euh chez Maruil. Mais le j'aime bien mon
sous-titre, c'est comment construire
demain autrement ?
Owen, tu as écrit des bouquins toi ?
Non.
Alors donne-moi un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Attendez pas que l'information vienne à
vous aller la chercher. Attendez pas
qu'on vous la serve. Sélectionnez-la.
Essayez d'apprendre. Remettez-vous en
cause tout le temps parce que ça va
beaucoup trop vite pour nous. Très
clairement, c'est comme quand on est
jeune et qu'on va à l'école parce que
nos parents nous le disent. Là, j'ai
l'impression qu'on doit aller à l'école
pour nous. Il faut faire très très vite
parce que de toutes les variables que
j'apprends et que je découvre hein,
encore une fois, c'est un conseil peu
avisé car avec peu de recul, l'éducation
est une variable sur laquelle on peut
faire beaucoup de bien, sur laquelle on
va vraiment aider. Ça permet la prise de
conscience, ça permet de donner du recul
et je me rends compte qu'on doit
vraiment s'éduquer d'urgence sur plein
de sujets. Soyez curieux. Et mine de
rien, amusez-vous quand même.
Raphaë, très bon conseil, Raphaël.
Très bon. Restez enthousiaste.
Restez enthousiaste. Restez euh J'avais
dit l'année dernière fois d'être fiable.
J'ajoute aujourd'hui cette touche de de
ne pas être blasé, de s'émerveiller en
fait de tous les détails qui vont vous
amener à ce qui est pour moi le summum
de l'homme, son autonomie.
Je vous remercie pour ce premier débat
autour des cryptonnaies. C'est un sujet
qui est vraiment très intéressant. On a
appris plein de trucs. On n pas pu poser
le quart du 10e de des des questions.
On a l'intro là. C'est en fait je pense
que c'est c'est on va faire un format
peut-être dédié à ça parce que nous on a
une communauté qui est quand même très
affuté sur certains trucs et il demande
de rentrer vraiment dans
mais on ne peut pas faire tout ça tout
de suite parce que il faut aussi euh que
les gens aient un peu d'appétence avec
ce sujet et ce type de débat qui comble
le fossé intergénérationnel est très
appétent et messieur nous voulions vous
remercier pour ce soir et À bientôt.
À bientôt.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]